the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hot but the play is just heating up at
the U.S Juniors and Senior championships
in St Louis the top players in the
country are ready to compete for a
national title in the capital of Chess
in America Underdog melanchian upset
top-seated vladimiricopian in the senior
section throwing him into a three-way
tie for first the lowest seed in the
junior Championship Arthur Shu won his
game catapulting him into a five-way
coal lead in the junior girls section 13
year old Phenom Alice Lee defeated
Gracie Persona and sits in a three-way
tie atop the standings Front Runners are
forming but the race is long and it's
just getting started who will be able to
pull away from the crowd day two of
heart racing chess coming up next
thank you
[Music]
foreign
championships we are here in the playing
hall waiting for players to arrive what
kind of exciting chess will we have
today let's go to the studio and find
out
[Music]
the Saint Louis chess club is proud to
present the 2023 edition of three
tournaments in one junior girls juniors
and seniors featuring The Best of young
talent and talented veterans our
coverage from Saint Louis begins now
[Music]
hi I'm woman Grandmaster Katarina name
Tova and I'm here with the Grand Master
yasser01. hey boy I tell you talk about
starting with the bang so many decisive
games yesterday especially in the
Juniors what a crazy round all games
were decisive absolutely hello everyone
and Welcome to our national
championships boy if you like decisive
games you sure came to the right place
except if you were a favorite look at
this in the girls well pardon me it was
in the Juniors that we had five for five
it was in the girls that we had three
for five and in the seniors three four
five lots and lots and lots of decisive
round games except if you were the
favorite if you're the favorite well you
had some issues let's take a look at the
standings gate and start with the girls
let's look at
in the
in the all won their first round and
then we have Carissa yet
kelsilu and Rose Atwell starting with
the draw Carissa being one of our
favorites got Nick and in the Juniors
in the Juniors we have a five-way tie
for first Brandon Jacobson abhimanyu
Mishra Andrew Hong Kirby gazarian and
Arthur Zhu holding their first round and
tying for first their Master Balaji
getting Nick there and got a loss and in
the seniors in the seniors we have
Gregory kaidanov Alex shabalov and
met games and Igor novikov Maxim plugy
Joel Benjamin and Dmitry gorevich having
drawn their first round at the risk of
repeating myself Vladimir Kobe and the
top seed also getting nicked with a loss
and tell us about the format
format of these tournaments there are
three 10 player round Robins this means
that one player plays everybody else in
their respective tournament the time
control is 90 minutes for first 40 moves
followed by 30 minutes for rest of the
game now there's 30 second increments
from move one
important to say there are no draw
offers allowed players have to play they
cannot agree on a draw and the
traditional scoring system is in place
as well we have 1.4 win half a point for
a draw and zero points for a loss and
our schedule Kate schedule is very
simple we have one round a day starting
always at 1 pm central time today we
have round two all the way to round five
then there is a rest day for all the
tournaments and players pick up on
Friday July 21st with round six and
continue to round nine if necessary
there are playoffs on Tuesday July 25th
and that rest day July 20th if you're
anywhere near the Central West End here
in St Louis come to the chess club and
celebrate our 15th anniversary and of
course we're delighted to have in studio
Christian boy talk about starting with a
bang huh Christian yesterday was fun
absolutely a good to see you our guys
and what an amazing start to these three
events we've had yesterday so many
decisive games and even the ones that
were not decisive in those ones we saw a
lot of Fighting Chess as well these
players are extremely tenacious but one
thing that these three uh events are
limited by is the age of the
participants in the junior section you
cannot be older than 20 and in the
senior section you have to be 50 or over
let's take a look at where our
participants stand in terms of their age
and we're going to start with the junior
girls roster as we see Rider feed and
master Alice Lee and Iris move only 13
years of age and Alice Lee is coming
into this event as one of the favorites
to win it all only 13 years of age we've
been doing commentary on her games for
so many years it feels like she has so
much experience in the back she's the
three-time world youth champion and also
she's coming into this event as the
number one ranked U.S girls under 21
just an impressive young lady and take a
look at that we have quite stringent
security measures in these three events
and she's getting wanted right Carissa
tried to escape for a second
saw her you're not going anywhere
I think Andrew is just leaving her his
coat or perhaps getting wanted by uh
Chris bird let's take a look at what's
happening in the Juniors we see ABI Manu
Mishra by far the youngest participant
in this event only 14 years of age what
an amazing player and let's highlight
him because I have to say yesterday I
was impressed by his play in the
previous year last year he was not
impressive in the first couple of rounds
but yesterday he was really resilient in
the face of a potential danger because
it was very close to getting help to a
drop by a much lower rated participant
in the event but he managed to break
through and won his event with won his
game with the white pieces impressive
start for the young man and let's take a
look at what's happening in the seniors
well we have the rating favorite
Vladimir aquapian coming in at 51 years
of age last year he started slowly just
like this year but he made it to the tie
breaks he was unable to win the
championship but he was def he will
definitely try to do so this year he's
51 years of age Invitational rating
2658 is coming in as the rating favorite
in this event and his three-time chess
only impaired gold medalist just an
incredibly accomplished player and you
know most of these players quite well
yeah sir tell us a bit about that wow
yeah just a it's a reunion for me as we
see Vladimir getting in his game phase
at the board uh Kate as we're getting
ready to start this round two but we've
got to set the table for our audience
and tell them the pairings do the honors
with the girls begin with the girls
let's start with the girls juniors here
we have Atwell facing Yip Mo playing
with Lou mangalam against Wu prasanna
against tank and Yen against Lee for
Carissa yet this will be your second
black in a row and the junior pairings
in the Juniors we have wanked against
dagupati guo against Zhu steerman
against Mishra Jacobson against gazarian
that's definitely a match to look at
absolutely against Liang as to the first
place uh faced each other Jacobson and
gazerian and in the scene
the parents let's look at the singers
round two glugy against wolf
Sherlock against danov up Yan against
Ruth novikov against kachian and
Benjamin against gurevich I sure will
have our eyes on them and Greg Gregory
kaidanos came and now the tournaments
have been switched around yeah we can
see it's been shuffled because seniors
are now in the main playing Hall and I
believe girls being pushed in the Attic
in the Attic yes now that is really not
the ad that's a really really nice
lecture room and World Chess Hall of
Fame hosts uh stars for lectures they
come in there it's a very nice uh room
but it isn't in the main room the main
playing hall because remember we got 15
boards and so you want to have lots of
Elbow Room let's say that you're not
jowl the job yeah we want to make sure
players are comfortable having a lot of
space around and we saw also the
monitors there here we have uh lee again
through yankian so all the girls are
sitting well ahead of the time just
thinking and kind of mentally preparing
what's ahead yeah as we saw they go
through the four fair play wanding and
no electronics people the play The
Players aren't even allowed to bring
their own pens by the way which I find
offensive because I really have a lucky
pen how about you Christian did you ever
have a lucky patch I I always find the
Lucky Penny right uh tournament I test a
lot of them but once I win a game with
one of them I would try to keep that for
the rest of the tournament or at least
until I lose a game exactly after I lose
a game
the lucky pen expires exactly it has an
expiration date yes yeah how about you
you have a lucky pet uh I had one pen
that I realized I got from my grand
grandmother so I would take it to my
games but then one day I couldn't for US
Champions and I don't know what happened
to that oh man and there they go they
are off and where would you like to
start shall we start with the ladies and
uh just uh well I think we can start
with that game I think it's quite an
Mish important one uh Josiah Sturman who
will try to bounce back after a
difficult loss yesterday against Mishra
who obviously I mean coming in as by far
the rating favorite in this one he will
try to win every single game and by the
way as you would expect in a competition
where five out of five games were
decisive we have a sicilian an open
Sicilian none of these c3s Bishop B5
checks these guys going for the main uh
line are we gonna see Dragon no no I
think we're going to see it neither
that's my prediction
not even the classical two nights
I think on either neither yes okay let's
see do we have it yes we do correct
no Mishra is a neither player
um for quite a few years I don't know if
he experimented with a lot of Sicilians
but by far the neither of is his main
State uh Bishop E3 kind of an invitation
to dance at the English if you will if
you want to try to stay in some kind of
uh night of Chartered Waters uh Knight
G4 E5 E7 E5 okay just going for uh
regular stuff Knight B3 okay this used
to be the main line for many many years
right exactly but now the players are
doing Knight F3 Knight E2 all sorts of
weird
Knight retreats
neither three night yeah somehow the
night feels better on B3 you're just
kind of out of the way you get to go
either Bishop e2g4 F2 F4 somehow when
the knights on F3 it's kind of standing
and we can see like in yesterday's game
Joel Benjamin was it that the Knight
went to A5 and C6 or at least wanted to
go yeah
and that was uh Patrick Wolfe game I
think it was uh
um Gregory oh it was Gregory yeah f2f3
all right let's just uh
go to the girls for a moment because
again sorry uh but for me Carissa you
know she's played on the women's Olympic
team she's played in the National
Women's championships you know I've
really uh come to expect incredibly
successful people are a team member with
her so many times also when she was
really much younger yeah she wasn't even
International master and she already
qualified to play World Team
Championship in Kazakhstan that was that
was amazing and she did really well
there too exactly so here she is 19
years Young comes in as the Invitational
rating favorite in the meanwhile by the
way Alice is actually Pastor on the
rating list but uh she's gets her second
black in a row due to the drawing of
lots bad luck on the drawing of lots
Carissa she starts with two blacks b2b3
now it's interesting how this if it has
flashes of fashion sometimes the b2b3
move uh gets played and then everybody
forgets about it immensely now it's
rehabilitated again knight uh C6 this
move is a little bit of a surprise but
it's also this B3 is specifically
against two E6 like I don't see B3
played against D6 very often because why
is that uh Christian my guess is that
whenever with the pawn on D6 already I'm
ready to play E5 I close the bishop on
B2 yes and then you can close me down
whereas when you play the move E6 it's
kind of hard for you to go back to the
that's re5 setups that's right I mean
you have to lose the temp you have to go
D6 and then E5 which is perfectly
possible and then I might play D4 before
you get an E5 exactly yes so Knight C6
Bishop B5
97 castles and we've caught up with the
players and Rose is considering pardon
me uh Carissa is considering should she
play a7a6 here which more or less once
you played 97 you kind of said I'm going
to play A6 give me the two Bishops as we
get a close-up of Karissa it's a little
bit weird though there is this B3 and
the bishop like wants to go there right
there's this empty space but Carissa is
thinking hard what to do maybe she's
considering D5 as well as well well by
the way this must be a very good version
for black right if we think about it
because you can get it from Rosso limo
like Knight C6 Bishop B5 E6 Castle
Knight G7 and generally right now in
preparation for A6 white place to move
Rook to E1 right make some space for the
bishop potentially to get back to F1
exactly now you get the same position
but you have the pawn on B3 instead of
this move Rook to E1 I think Rook to E1
is much more useful than B3 okay it's a
different type of usefulness right but
uh generally Rook to E1 is considered to
be much much better as we can see uh
Carissa is asking the questions the
pertinent questions very very good move
A6 I like this what are you going to do
are you going to give me uh the bishop
pair or are you going to retreat on a
not so optimal Square potentially E2 for
example I'm expecting Bishop take C6
Knight takes C6 Bishop B2 and trying to
provoke my opponent to play F7 and F6
I'd like to turn our attention to
another star yeah
absolutely and the girls uh Yang Yin and
Alice Lee so Alice um
Petrov the Petrov has a great reputation
for solidity if you want to play a good
solid game as black the Russian defense
or the Petrov defense is a go-to main
weapon of today's elite players if
there's an issue with it it's genuinely
considered that it's hard for black to
press if white the opponent wants to
make a draw and one of the ways that
white can do that to make a draw I mean
is to go Queenie to Queen E7 D3 Knight
back Bishop G5 and essentially a queen
trade is forced and whites ever so
marginally better that's not what
rooying in played she played Bishop to
D3 trying to kick the Knight away
immediately D5 and now she played Queen
E2 hoping to provoke her opponent Alice
into playing Queen E7 and then Knight C3
and again we're talking you know just
very very marginal uh edge here for
white but check this out Alice
sacked upon
take the phone I recapture but then she
wants to Castle quickly and get the Rook
on the fire exactly well let's take a
look I mean a Pawn's a pawn uh in my
expert opinion by the way uh Castle
quickly for how many years of experience
yes
we're upon ahead uh well rookie might be
met by rookie one and that's a little
awkward maybe Knight C6 Bishop I mean
you do have the two Bishops right
there's no question and if you were to
post your Bishop quickly on D5 you you
you might start talking about a
compensation but where would you go
Knight C6 right 96 very natural movement
and for me equally a natural move
playing my Pawn to D4 Bishop E6 Bishop
E6 yes yeah kind of a natural move okay
Knight C3 I'm developing kind of
intimating that this might be on my
agenda night before
yeah kind of feels a little bit
necessary now yes and uh well I don't
know I mean
yet the two Bishops Christian but yeah
is it full compensation we we talk very
often about the engines solving chess
and not having ways to uh be creative in
the opening but in fact is the other way
around uh the engines have shown us that
a lot of things that we thought
previously that cannot be played they
are actually quite playable and this is
exactly one of those instances and
there's a specific game uh mvl uh vashir
Le Graf versus Anish from 2021 and this
was by the way this is the only game
that I see in my database with this move
Bishop to E7 and this is move what move
six right right it is very early on so
Bishop to E7 definitely has been
analyzed I would assume this was some
sort of a rapid encounter between these
two players but it just goes to show
that with the new engines we are ready
to give this type of sacrifices and it
does say that after Bishop takes E4 as
you guys were mentioning castle castle
it is C5 that is the proposed move by
the engine Rook 28 is also definitely an
idea in the position but in general what
you want to do is focus on stopping
white from playing D4 and taking a space
in the center how do you do that by
playing the move C5 now white has a
couple of options you can play D3 this
to my eyes at least is a bit too passive
after D3 I will go Knight C6 I will
include my knight potentially jump in
the center with Knight to D4 Rook to E8
a lot of things are coming with tempo
for black it just feels like you're not
getting uh the sort of play that you
would like to get with white pieces full
compensation in my estimation for a
black if you decide to go with D3
you can also go with D4 and this is
going to invite what I think is an end
game that Alice Lee has analyzed at home
take take Knight C6 Queen takes d8 most
likely Rook takes d8 and this is the
type of position that she seems to be
ready to play
um it reminds me of a marshall uh more
or less something along those lines
black gives up a pawn for the bishop
pair long-term compensation in the end
game and most likely is going to fizzle
out into a draw and this is exactly what
I'm expecting as well from this game
obviously Alice Lee knows what she's
doing one hour and 33 minutes on her
clock Rue Yang Yen only one hour and 23
minutes and I'm trying to remember
I think it was this game from the US
Women's Championship between Irina crush
and Alice Lin which Alice or perhaps it
was from the American Cup I think it was
from the American Cup a very similar
Pawn sacrifice early in the opening by
Alice it was an English and she gave
upon in a very uh weird manner that
became only recently quite popular
she didn't manage to find the
compensation in that game right I
remember specifically we'll see if she
manages to find it in today's game
because I'm sure Rue Yang is probably
going to take on it for she has to take
on e4 if you don't take only four then
your whole setup does make a lot of
sense because I'm going to go there we
go yeah yeah the bishop D3 Queen E2 yeah
basically is saying if you don't move
your knight I'm gonna take it and win a
pawn you have to take them
she refused to move her now maybe the
alternative was Knight C3 to put a
little bit more pressure on the center
but then why did we want our Queen on E2
exactly then I just take on C3 and I get
a better version of the Knight C3 idea
exactly I'd like to turn our attention
to the game of shria and Rochelle woo
for a moment Rochelle uh one of our
tournament leaders in the girls section
as she won uh her opening game last the
first round uh Sicilian and this time
not the open this is the what I was
complaining about the weapon uh with a
c2c3 and black grabs the center now one
of the tricky things about the Lapin is
that when you're black you always have
to be cognizant that white might capture
this Pawn on C5 and the desirable Queen
takes King takes D1
you're not getting full compensation if
the king manages to run out to C2 I'm
used to seeing the move Bishop G4
and for me the move Bishop F5 well I I
mean that could be ill-time or wrongly
placed Bishop Bishop to E3 once again
I'm I'm saying to you white is saying to
her opponent like hey look you know I
may take this pawn and then what are you
going to do about it and one more thing
you want to be careful anytime like the
the e-file is blocked with Bishop E3 or
Bishop E2 is that the white may think
about playing C4 and D5 exactly because
a moment ago let's say in this position
if I play Knight F6 and I could go C4
I'm very very yeah yeah and I'm gonna go
D5 next move your queen away I'll go D5
next well the check just catches me for
that single moment that turn and you'll
take the pawn so you're right the move
Bishop e pardon me the bishop E3 is kind
of a precursor to
C4 again I'm thinking it's time to take
the pawn Rochelle says I'll play play E6
and then this is a very typical idea in
the alapan a dual purpose move on the
one hand any captures of D4 could be met
with Knight B5 I'm not going to let you
take my knight rather I'm going to
threaten a family fork or a royal fork
and I'll be able to capture on D4 again
you might say any Knight takes D4 boy I
sure would rather have my Bishop on G4
than on F5 okay so Knight A3 Knight F6
Knight B5 immediately immediately
and this is a the moment that Rochelle
has stopped right here and I'm seeing
problems for black okay so the real
problem I'm seeing that if you go back
you just step back and well I'll just
take the pawn and this is a real
challenge how are you ever going to win
that pawn back and don't get I can
always play Knight D6 check as well if
you play Rook C8 similar story my
intention is to take you're just going
to play castle exactly right that's what
I mean I think there is this one move
maybe and well you know you put your
King on the queen side okay okay but I
will tell you why she will play castle
and I'm sure she's going to play this
move almost with 100 certainty because
she played up to this point yeah Knight
to F6 Allah Tempo okay one hour and 32
minutes right wow yeah the thing is if
you take on C5 right now as white you
have to go Castle there's no other but
better move Castle is the only move that
maintains the balance in the position
you cannot take on C5 because you lose a
piece after Queen takes D5 and Bishops
exactly C5 so you cannot exchange the
Queens because then you're left with the
king in the center and Knight D5 Knight
C7 comes with tremendous consequences so
you have to know that you have to do
Castle right and uh it only makes sense
that against Knight B5 you will probably
have to go Castle as well so she spent a
few minutes trying to understand whether
she's not missing anything uh very
serious and you know followed her
preparation which most likely is Castle
okay but if you don't mind just
continuing that moment for a second
after castles uh the king I don't know
that King on uh on C8 it it kind of
makes it a Target doesn't it how do you
take advantage of it well okay go Queen
A4 that was the first move that came
into my mind yes now you're much worse
much more foreign
that would be much better because most
likely with the spawn F4 you don't even
threaten to take on B5 because you have
Queen A8 and then you control Knight to
B8 uh defense right but the bishop is on
E3 so unfortunately you cannot focus on
that side of the board just yet and you
also have to be ready for this A6 idea
which kicks the Knight away so Queen A4
not a good move in the position and in
fact there's there's only one good move
in the position take on C5 take on C5
yeah okay if you just wait I think I'm
just
right and I think you might be in
trouble after that gotcha so
um it kind of forces things
most likely you cannot take a tank
and then maybe bishop to C4 yes right
this actually seems to be just simple
for white for white so you have to do
something other than Bishop takes C5
which is Queen takes D1 take we exchange
and then you finally go Knight to D5
it's all about the focus on the pawn on
C5 how do you get to it you have a
couple of ways Knight to D7
unfortunately after Knight D7 B4 you
might be in trouble you're not getting
that pawn back you don't want that but
you can go Knight to D5 and this seems
to be some sort of preparation some sort
of theory and black equalizes in most
instances you are a pawn down you will
recapture that white still has to put
her King to C1 most likely get it out of
Dodge off the D file and you have to
spend some time to do those things it
seems to be very very close to equality
this position objectively still some
work to be done for a black to fully
equalize but objectively I think she's
very closely
good to see how Rochelle is dealing with
recapturing that pawn but what if we go
now to Juniors absolutely
bring up the game between Arthur goo and
Arthur Zhu as this is a
rather different position than I
expected it comes out of these G6 uh rui
Lopez now G6 is really a move uh vasilis
mislav has played so many openings and
he's enriched so many
new ideas that in so many openings you
could almost say Smith and I would say
smeselov was well he wasn't the first to
play G7 G6 he definitely enriched it and
so to my mind you know you could almost
call this the Smith rui Lopez a lot of
people play Knight E7 as a Prelude 97 D7
D6 and then played G7 G6 but G7 G6 uh
smesoff was like really one of the first
to really say this is actually
completely legit it seems slow but as
you'll see it does get a very unusual
positions B7 B5 now
we could stop right here and say the old
guys the really really old guys would
say hey you've got the Central Pawn Duo
you've got these two people very good
all the pieces around and you can't play
like this
you just can't you know Black's giving
up too much and then the engines say oh
no no no this is actually completely
legit because uh I'm ready after castles
to play the move D7 uh D5 get my fair
share of the center so you have to
occupy the center but check this out 985
and B2 is a Target and that's what he he
goes for and okay you still have this
really nice Central Ponce like but you
gave up a pesky yeah on uh B2 to get it
and we are caught up with the players
and I believe we're still in theory but
I'm going to have to rely upon Christian
to tell me what the state of the theory
is between Arthur you and Arthur's you
um it doesn't seem like we're still
living in the trenches of the theory
right now let's see not in the trenches
night takes B where did we where did we
disappear where did we go it was at this
point actually A4 is the last is the
first novelty but the novelty in the
position previously Bishop to B3 was
played previously I see just to attack
this night before maybe try to go Queen
to C3 next things of that nature
she decided he decided excuse me uh
arcturer to go A4 is it possible that is
a home-cooked preparation because when
you look at time it's very possible it's
a very good time it's a certainty I
would say
one hour and 32 minutes I mean you don't
play things so fast if you don't know
what you're doing especially in this
type of positions right you sacrificed
upon you did get some compensation for
it uh the lack of uh the dark Square
Bishop for uh Black's defense next to
his King
but you have to know what you're doing
right and to be honest because I used to
play this as black did you yes yes yes
but a misspent childhood it wasn't
really childhood
mostly in my 20s and I quickly realized
it's just a trash opening
I I dropped it after maybe like a year a
year and a half
um it's very dangerous specifically
because of this line
really yes and I'm sure that with the
new engines it's probably even worse and
we see art review just really thinking
hard for almost 10 minutes already right
because this is not this is that that's
uh something new and he needs to figure
out how to respond to this knowledge
okay so just throwing out a move and
it's not the only move Bishop B7 is
another but I I'm very used to seeing
the move Rook on A8 to B8 in a very wide
number of rui Lopez defenses right so go
ahead uh Christian and show us the
compensation after Rook B8 Rook to B8
how would it go how would the lines um
now I will continue following it up with
Bishop to beat now you transpose into
the previous uh stuff but now I don't
know okay I could give back the pawn and
then my Rook as well but how do you do
it how do I give back what's your next
useful move in the position right I want
to play both C6 and D6
at the same time right or F6 and Knight
E5 yeah right which one is it I know
okay wait uh let's say D6 right okay
let's say should we start with D6 well I
had an idea first which was very
horrible and that was to move the
knights to A5 okay but that's a really
bad because there is Queen C3 a problem
so moving the Knight away so how would
you do it after Bishop like 96 96 by the
way is the best movie in episode yeah no
I was just saying that I cannot leave to
A5 right now okay
that's that's a nice little uh attack
yes yes unfortunately you cannot go
there okay I'm a pawn up you know I'm a
pond grubber Knight to D6 of course Rook
PA yes
I'll just come back Queen C3 let's give
you a check first let's see where I go
now I have a problem I don't know if I
want to play F6 or King back okay let's
say King back okay King back yeah go
ahead do your worst let's try 92. it's
just simple uh development of the pieces
and again my question is how do you
develop your pieces with an iPhone D6
you no longer are able to play the move
this we you would love to play the move
D6
yeah my knight I mean I'm going through
contortions for my extra Pawn if I go
Knight E8 in order to play D6 E8 right
now I have a feeling I'm going to start
pushing my pawns well I understand I
mean you your compensation already feels
immense I mean okay your Rooks are
connected and everything okay I'm going
to be
foreign
H5 to be honest I have all the time in
the world okay
um we'll keep an eye on this uh I also
wanted to uh bring up the game of Mishra
for a moment because I I always love
these games where the kings are on
opposite flanks because that basically
is a bell that's that's gonna be a fight
it's gonna be a fight but I'm gonna go
after your king and you're gonna go
after my king and by the way it's a
necessity there's just no way other way
around it and in this game Josiah is
Castle queenside and we see his one hour
and 35 minutes so he's still in
preparation wow talk about fast and
again I reminded of the senior game
yesterday between Gregory kaidanov and
Patrick Wolff this was uh remember the
whole H5 and Knight D5 business
in that game by the way Patrick captured
with the bishop essentially avoiding uh
what Josiah played uh
with a knight takes Pawn takes Bishop F5
Bishop E2
Mishra check
forcing white to play G3 okay but wait a
minute that's a that is like it takes
you to Tempe you moved your Bishop once
you moved your Bishop twice in order to
provoke one little detail
my first instinct is to say you can't
spend so much time a Tempe in the
opening and especially as black and
white uh you know picked up the gauntlet
and said okay since you forced me to put
my Pawn on G3 I won't Castle kingside
I'll Castle Queen side do your worst
Knight D7 King B1 castles H3 and again
here here it comes I'm going to go G4
and you know throw everything I have
including the kitchen sink against your
king and then for Mishra he's going to
look to do the same on the queen side
and Bishop back G4 and we caught up with
the players your first instinct Kate
well I kind of understand the bishop H4
check right make sure I avoided any like
shorts Castle short Castle so he wants
to have this fight where kings are on
opposite side and we see the pawns goes
to G4 through G3 so white is also losing
a Tempo so at the end of the day Mishra
probably you know a Tempo not
necessarily two yes right
um
lost did they lose
sure because you went Bishop Jack and
Bishop so he lost the tempo and he has
kingside on the opposite side opposite
side yeah I don't know how I if I was
the youngest Grandmaster ever then
probably I would be very happy about
whatever I got got a full-bodied fight
but in terms of who which side do you
prefer do you like White's position here
better do you like black uh I like this
position for white I'm used to playing a
lot of these positions with wide open
Sicilian where I attack on the king side
move my king to B1 and try to survive on
the queen side so these positions are
way more comfortable for me for white
exactly and you've and you're playing
for F4 you're playing for takes
well at some point you got to play for
F4 I guess yes whether you you start
with the takes and uh Christian over to
you uh this specific position uh Josiah
is this all Theory where did we leave
Theory I believe H3 was uh the novelty
okay that game if I remember correctly I
was watching a 16 game but yeah okay it
does seem like that was also the move
that stopped abimano in his tracks and
then he started thinking about what he
needs to do as you guys were analyzing
uh most likely Bishop to H4 is only
aimed against white castling short side
right because now after you play G3
castling uh short doesn't make a lot of
sense right I'm going to go H4 as black
and I'm going to break your Pawn
structure in front of your king so
perhaps you give up a Tempo but you
force White Castle alongside which to my
eyes it's a nice invitation and I will
accept it because I usually cast
alongside them I try to check made you I
used to to play these type of positions
with the white pieces not so much
actually not at all with the black
pieces I was never a neither of player
actually were you guys ever neither oh
definitely that was a big big time uh I
thought the night Earth was the funnest
thing in the world until I got out
prepared once
I think this is uh lost without play
without doing it never became a much
stronger player because I I was always
shying away from this type of crazy
openings what do you have in front of
you uh Christian
between acopian and Douglas root and
this is a theoretical battle in the
French take a look at what's happening
in this one they're following
um theory in this line Knight to F3
Bishop to D6 and I believe this is the
moment after Knight to E4 Knight to H5 1
hour and 34 minutes for a copy on
Douglas with 1 hour and 35 minutes so
they were exchanging blows they knew
exactly what they were doing but this is
the first time Douglas is taking a very
long thing 20 minutes he spent at this
point and he played this move G6
which unfortunately is not a very good
move because it just weakens the king
too much much better would have been
tried to go for Bishop to D7 just
typical uh development in the position
Bishop to D7 maybe bishop to E8 if you
really want to hit this Knight if you
feel uncomfortable with this Knight
hanging around your king Bishop D7
Bishop E8 makes a lot of sense then get
the queen on F6 and try to do something
on the file he played this move G6 but
unfortunately after Knight to G3 the
king just simply becomes a bit too weak
to my taste and to the engine stays as
well Rook takes F3 Queen takes F3 Knight
to D2 I understand that's nice that's a
nice uh way of exchanging a pair of
Rooks but the problem is after Queen to
E3 Knight takes F1 Rook takes F1 let's
say
where are your Defenders
next to your king you don't have any
Defenders the Knight on e4 blocking
everything around uh for the bispawn D3
is no longer with us uh The Rook on f8
no longer with us so now all I have to
do is find a way to get this G if I
manage to get H4 H5 in play the game is
over right so you really have to stop me
from doing that you don't have a dark
sword Bishop protecting your king either
so maybe ideas of Queen to H5 H4 H5 are
going to be in play in this position I
just simply don't like uh the situation
of the black king right now and I think
Jacobian is probably in driver's seat
and he knows it we have a an exchange
sacrifice on the board yes uh and by the
way he didn't it seems like he didn't
take on F3 with a queen yet he's
considering maybe taking with a G point
with the G Pawn yeah that was uh that
was my question for you uh it's possible
yes
it's possible not that good though it
seems like after Knight G5 black has
quite significant compensation yes
suddenly uh but he yeah he's he's paused
he's definitely passed temptation is is
is strong yes well I can I can resist
everything except Temptations but uh we
failed yesterday we failed uh we've got
uh already one round in our books but we
should have been predicting who is going
to win the tournament and
Kate we're going to rely upon you to
Lead the Way start with the start with
your prediction for the girls
Championship who who do you like in the
girls so the girls juniors is really
filled with so many amazing names I mean
we saw karisai there Alice Lee and
Rochelle who's super experienced players
I'm gonna go with Alice Lee because I
think she's having an amazing year she's
playing her really best and uh yeah I
think maybe this is going to be her year
with the girls juniors I tell you what
I'm going to join you on this one just
because I mean I she is on a roll she's
just played as
interviewed yesterday with Christian she
said I went into this tournament I went
into this tournament and her results
just kept piling up if you look at the
Invitational rating list right now Alice
Lee when she was invited was more or
less 50 rating points behind Carissa do
you know that this Summer She surpassed
uh Carissa so I mean Alice Lee looks
like the force not only of the future
but of the present so I'm going to join
you how about you uh Christian what's
your choice on the girls well as the my
Jedi mind trick work it's not worth it
no it's not gonna work with Carissa okay
this one just for the simple fact that
you guys yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
took Alice right the current rating
favorite she started off well with the
victory careers are not so well with a
draw but I still have faith that she's
going to be able to take the
championship home darrish in our
production team darush is going to join
you as well he likes Carissa and in the
Juniors once again you have to lead us
off yeah who do you like that's tough
pick because we have this this super
young
after
evermanio Mishra but I'm gonna go actual
with Brandon Jacobson I lied how
yesterday he said you know this is my
last year I think this is the year to
actually go for it and win it and I felt
like he has this Force to actually you
know lead him to that win so I'm gonna
pick him okay
okay very good and uh I'll be the tie
breaker this time Christian who do you
like in the Juniors well look on this
one I'm going to have a wild card I'm
going to go with the actual wild card
that is Josiah Silverman because he's my
student at the University of Missouri so
uh
use some confidence in this young guys I
like it now and I'll pick Josiah very
good for me I mean I grew up with Bobby
Fischer as a hero nobody nobody would
ever break Bobby Fisher's record of 15
years young to get the Grand Master
title the fact that it's been done not
once not twice but many times including
by Judith pogar as well Mishra the
world's youngest Grandmaster ever I I
mean that that just overwhelms me I'm
gonna go with Mishra on the Juniors
do we Okay and we have Darius Schwartz
we're mastering the production and he's
also picking Brandon Jacobson okay and
then finally we come to the Legends uh
not only uh talents of the past but
according to our intro talents of today
yes and a lot of Hall of Famers really
right spectacular players there are so
many titles I was going through their
bias we have a lot of world juniors
championships of course U.S Champions
U.S general Champions this time I'm
gonna go with Joel Benjamin I lied how
yesterday he was saying you know my
preparation is done I prepared well
before the tournament and I'm ready to
just go here and fight so I think he has
a big chances absolutely and he's won
every single national championship title
there could be whether it be high school
national champions
previously the senior Championship he's
a U.S Champion so he's literally won
every single title including being an
Olympian uh go for it Christian don't
tell me you've got a a player
and the seniors
I do not getting their
no I will take um Malik Malik said he's
had a great first round he did he showed
some
um good fighting Spirit he was
courageous in the face of those pawns
coming yeah I sent her that C4 D4 I
think he's determined right um and he's
had some good spells as a coach I think
it's time for him to have a great spell
as a player as well I'm going to take
him as the champion
defending Champions man I mean Alex
shabalov look at that Shabba dabba doo
he comes into this tournament with the
right Spirit the right mindset he won
his first round game so being a little
bit unfair by taking one of the players
already in the first place but yeah
shabby's my pick and uh darush again
again a Grandmaster in our production he
likes Gregory kaidana very very
impressed by Gregory's
well-spokenness
and the interview he had with you uh
Christian Gregory is always a great big
very very nice and uh quite the rest of
their seniors by the way and there we
see Gregory kaidanova at work in the
office as we'll go to his game why not
let's just bring up Gregory's game there
he is today he plays uh my pick as
shibalov and let's see how we got here
this looks like yes okay one of those
Joko pianos and you never know what
you're going to get when you play a Joko
piano everybody and his brother plays a
c2c3 but the move D7 D6 what that's done
it's it's set up an early move Knight A5
when the idea is you want to hunt down
this bishop with the move Knight A5 so
if you if you did fall for C2 C3 and you
thought okay I'm just going to do my
traditional stuff Knight D2 then the
problem is Knight A5 Bishop B5 Bishop D7
you're forced to part with the light
Square bishop and then White's Advantage
is thought to be non-existent I always
thought D6 is like a signal move that
they want to attack with the Knight
because with D6 black is defending the
opponent E5 they are ready to free the
Knight to go exactly and that's why we
see the move a2a4 because it does give
the bishop a square on A2 also there are
reasons why you want to play A3 for
exactly the same uh you give your Bishop
a square and maybe maybe maybe before
okay Knight A5 Bishop A2 C5 and this is
one of the ways that white pardon me
black fights for control of the center
he moves his Knight away with a gain of
time so he can play the move C5 okay so
far so good everything looks kind of
more or less normal and we have a D4
takes takes caught up with the players
I'm assuming we're still in theory on
this one because it looks like quite
frankly everybody's moves have been
pretty standard how would you assess the
position okay A little imbalance it
looks nice for white to have the center
and now also the knight from B1 is ready
to jump to C3 Square kind of happened
the pawn disappeared right
but what is black gonna do I'm not sure
because black can also caption before
and maybe push one of them but we have
to be careful about E6 square and the
Queen
say say takes takes and if you were
thinking that this was a French defense
it would be easy to imagine that after
the move D5 you might think oh okay this
came from a French defense especially if
you were to see a move like e594 here
I'm thinking you're gonna have to
capture on D5
what do you think yeah I think so as
well because if we push the pawn to E5
the Knight goes to E4 Bishop to C5 in
the future whoops yeah let's not do that
I have an Initiative for black big time
there okay uh well uh we'll keep this on
the back burner as we throw it over to
oh Christian I was before we jump to
Christian thank you for watching and
telling your friends where you're
hanging out but also for joining the
conversation yes
sweets sweets sweet tweets this one is
from doctor on Twitch and he asks given
the changes that have taken place in
chess theory and practice over the past
50 years how do you envision chess 50
years from now for me if you don't mind
I'll go first on this one that's easy
fish are random
because for me the problem with the
modern chess and the modern chess
engines is the databases are growing
exponentially we're playing thousands
and thousands of new games and opening
theory is being advanced
so much so that sometimes we just come
in and they start at move 20. and that's
just that's just crazy whereas when you
watch the Fisher random tournament and
you see the players stop at move three
and four and five I say you know that's
where the players can show their
creativity 50 years from now where will
chest be keep I think that we might we
may see like more openings
creative lines that players will be
going for because now I still feel the
theories sometimes it's a little Limited
in given openings there are few lines
that players are going for but now with
the invention of like you know computers
and very artificial intelligence we may
see some more creative lines and more
ways to go in openings Christian what do
you think jump it well definitely not
chess 960. I know
he shot me down on that one I'm gonna
have to shut you down with the classical
chess is here to stay and he's going to
be here to stay for uh the remain well
the future uh decades I I do think that
uh your fear is unwarranted yes sir
because we do see some of the lines uh
start at move 20 but we also see new
fresh ideas very early on in the
openings and I only think with the
emergence of stronger and stronger
engines that that is exactly how chess
is going to expand we're going to see
new ideas as early as move three four
five things of that nature and that's
going to infuse a lot of new energy into
the game of chess for the next few
decades decades look chess 960 is just a
way to have fun I I don't feel
the comparative nature that you get with
classical chess whenever we have this
chess 960 events they're fun right but
that competitive spirit is still there
but not as in high alert as with
classical jazz well I just gotta remind
you remember you were in Oslo we were in
Oslo together we're watching that fisher
World Championship yeah and you were
helping Bobby yeah and I was
commentating Wesley so was the winner
and that is felt like that event that I
remind you that was pretty fun Christian
it was pretty fun it was very
competitive but also it was a world
championship ah so you know whenever
there's a world championship by the
timeline it doesn't matter if it's no
castling chess chess 960 whatever type
of Chess you want there's a world
championship title on the line and
everybody's going to take it seriously
okay that was once we we actually have
another one too uh let's go to our
second tweet again thank you for uh
joining uh the the program okay this one
is from Rob Nikolai on YouTube and he
has how do you judge the future of U.S
Chess at top level with several Nations
moving up with so many talented
youngsters will the US stay competitive
wow yesterday well I gotta say I mean
India and China have been nothing short
of amazing
both those Nations
if you went back 30 years were really
not there I mean they there was one
vicious for India and China well it even
had Chinese chess so it wasn't even
playing Western chess today
holy smokes when you think about Chennai
the Olympiad and Chennai and the the
Indian teams that were competing and the
youth that India has and the youth that
China has yeah those two nations are
definitely
incredible but I gotta tell you the U.S
yeah we're competing we're really really
really serious and when I look at these
Junior players I go yeah we've got a
bright future jump jump in your thoughts
I mean we see also right because we see
youngsters all over the place feel given
computer Now accessibility everywhere
and internet there are a lot of
youngsters everywhere playing online
non-stop I had you know during chess
camps here kids we have a break and they
get their phone they play on chess.com
they're like guys we have a break you
know take a snack you have five minutes
before the next lesson and they still go
and play chess so because there is this
access everywhere I feel like youngsters
are going to be just like you know
getting more and more stronger
everywhere in the world but I agree with
you I think here in the US we have so
many young people I mean Mishra he's the
youngest GM ever honestly and there are
a lot of other young kids who are
playing their best so I'm not worried
about the us as a nation in next 50
years now coach you you have a special
seat in the table for this question
because you're actively recruiting
players for the St Louis University uh
chess bro
the University of Missouri sorry let me
take that back I got St Louis
you're actively scouring the planet
looking for junior players where do you
scour best no I have to say I mean uh
India is a big Hub uh China as you were
you guys were mentioning is a big Hub as
well
um Russia Iran is a big one right now
and Iran just got their third 2700 level
Grand Master wow yesterday I think
Tabata Bay followed the parhamaksudulu
and alireza firuja who moved to France
but this is a nation that in 2004 I
think got their first Grand Master it
was uh Salem OR like their first 2600
Grand Master so this is a very novel
Nation that's producing incredible
results and I think it all comes down to
systems of nurturing these players and
we here in the United States we do have
great systems and specifically here at
the Saint Lucia's club we nurture the
players and you've been seeing this case
okay because you're doing all these
camps and you see these youngsters
coming along through the lines and these
guys have great Futures I mean we have
Christopher you who is not present here
we have abimanu the youngest uh the
strongest 14 year old on the planet
right now so we definitely have an
amazing future I do believe that the USS
is going to stay competitive for the
years come missing Jeffrey Zhang I
remember
he's already in the US oh my gosh he's
established he's been alive right around
for a while right oh my gosh
I was having a lesson with like Kids
Academy here in St Louis kids four to
five years old
and they knew the rules
like 45 years old wow that blows me away
I was impressed Rocky as the night moves
this way and they were having this like
um story chess they were like oh there's
this kitchen in the Middle where we want
to have our pieces and I was like sure
let's get another piece to the kitchen
amazing really incredible you said bring
him in I better beat him now get them
while they're young my goodness we have
a social media director we always ask
all of you to send us questions via
Twitter but we have our own social media
person who is having birthday happy
birthday begin
24 years old and having led the U.S
women's Olympic team uh began wow okay
women Grandmaster we live to Christian
to say the full name accurately
Christian your job
once more once more for the crowd
good job so happy birthday bagging we
are so happy to have you here I think
she's doing incredible job yeah sorry
incredible job with the social media
pictures everything absolutely uh
congratulations and let's turn to the
games because uh talking about games
where players are castled on opposite
side of the board uh the the fight
between Joe Benjamin and Dimitri gurvich
is nothing short of
absolutely Dynamic okay exactly that's
what it is can we move back yes yeah
we'll go back okay classical uh two
nights uh Sicilian Bishop G5 uh Queen D2
Bishop E7 castles castles and this is
setting the stage uh I'm gonna go
kingside you're gonna go Queen side
let's go H4 let's get started Knight
takes D4 Queen takes D4 Bishop D7 now
normally you might be thinking as white
well let me just take this Knight and if
you recapture I'm going to take the pawn
well the first thing is that's not the
best pawn that you've ever won strangely
enough for example after Bishop takes
Bishop takes Queen takes Bishop C6 you
might ask yourself what have I really
and then the second thing is crazily
enough even after G takes F6 you know
doubled up the pawns it's not so easy to
just go out there and you know sack the
black king there's not a lot of uh
attackers King h8 Rook G8 is pretty
standard so none of that why the new
long Castle usually do not want to get
rid of your dark Square Vision exactly
right that's a rule exactly F3 Queen B8
move I want to stop here a little bit
because it's actually a pretty cool move
but it's not that automatic that you
move Queen and you block The Rook in the
corner but here we are supporting B5
that's what it's all about right B5 B4
and then what you said about blocking
the rook in the corner and once I play
A5 then that rook in the chord area is a
happy camper but it's about getting in
those moves B5 A5 B4 quickly as can be H
uh five and when that pawn gets to H6
it's really really not pleasant H6 and
now this one for me was a bit of a
surprise Bishop H4 you've now got a hook
right so that basically means that G4 G5
is going to be shortly on White's agenda
B7 B5 I've got this yeah going I've got
the feeling we're still in theory but
it's sharp sharp sharp oh oh Christian
you got another very sharp positioned on
your board that's different from this
one I'm looking at the Juniors because
we have some very very interesting
battles in that one and one in
particular this game between Andrew Hong
and Jason Liang and Jason had a great
first part of the game yesterday against
Brandon Jacobson he got a very
significant Advantage unfortunately for
him he took that poison Pawn on him G5
um and uh that was not the correct
decision let's take a look at what's
happening in today's game he's with the
black pieces and he's playing this well
this started as a Karo Khan right now it
looks more like a French with the bishop
still on C8 and now we get this move F6
allowing Queen to G6 a very particular
um strange move because I mean allowing
Queen to G6 infiltration so close to
your king doesn't seem like the right
way of doing things especially since I
can follow this we take on F6 and H4
right it feels like you're almost
getting not checkmated but you're going
to lose some material you cannot take
this Pawn on H4 because of Bishop to H6
this is game over this is the actual
idea behind this whole setup for white
so Rook to G8 came on the board this is
what we have right now and it's a
critical position because white can
actually uh go astray quite easily with
very natural moves by the way Queen to
H6 the most natural give you a check
and I'll take on G5 right absolutely
most natural most natural if you take on
G5 it feels like to have some
significance terrible I can go Knight E2
and get my knight closer I can give you
a check first if I want to it looks good
right right you don't have this powerful
complex controlling everything in the
center right right like you have it with
the pawn on F6
the problem is once you take on G5 Rook
AJ black is much better
after Rook to h8 oops this forces yeah
and now I hide on G8 oops protecting my
Rook at the same time yeah sure this
still looks good for white I'm a pawn up
I'm just going to get back with my queen
I'm a pawn up no problem right your king
is completely open not so fast Queen to
E8 right getting close to picking up
your uh Pawn on G6 there's no way you
can defend that and you can try to go
Queen to D3 I'm going to follow it up
with King to G7 and then I'm going to
take I have the two Bishops I have a
very powerful Center that at some point
is going to put into motion D4 E5 open
up the light Square Bishop once that
happens you're in big big trouble as
white in fact right now the engine is
saying minus 1.2 so quite a significant
Edge for a black you have to be very
careful because once again it's
Temptation you see this track you see
the capture on G5 you see that if black
captures you're going to get a lot of
weaknesses around the king and you can
get tempted to do that it's not the
correct way of doing business as white
you have to do this and right now you
have to go check it will try first
only after Rook to G6 now you can take
on G5 this is the correct way take on G5
Rook to E3 perhaps Bishop to D2 things
of this nature it's still complex it's
not that easy but I have to say most
likely with such an exposed King I would
prefer having white right this position
how about you guys uh me too I like
white uh
just because of the exposed King and
that's the that that's what it's all
about now having said that the two
Bishops and you know what else I'm
putting I see that Jason Liang yes one
hour 21 minutes which means he's still
probably in his home preparation whereas
Andrew Hong is one hour so sometimes
when you see maybe you are a little bit
better but your opponent is in their
whole preparation yeah maybe then you're
like uh I'm not you start a question I
think your decisions and that can be an
advantageous for for black I'd like to
turn our attention to the game of Igor
novikov and alexette for just a second
because here I'm going to show my you
know Prejudice I've got this you know
career experience
doubtlessly the the chess engines are
saying this is okay and the you know
Black's position White's position or
triple zeros or something I hate this
position for black like a visceral
hatred I think that this position is
like dead lost
really really like lost lost lost so the
problem that I have with this is black
is white is going to play B5 okay in the
future he's going to play B4
in the future he's going to capture on
C6 and then he's going to play B5 so
he's going to have two battering
rams hitting this Pawn on C6 and by the
time all of the that debris is cleared
I'm going to have a protected pass Pawn
on C5 so strategically I think black is
lost
black has to rely exclusively
with E5 right so let's see so so let's
do it consequently move by move B4 E5
B4 now in the good old days uh before
the chess engines became so strong the
chess engine programs would play the
move E4 which I would just Embrace and I
would say okay after E4 the chess engine
algorithm would evaluate the position as
favorable for black just because of all
the squares and then after you see the
move Knight D2 Knight B3 Knight A5 well
if there's such a thing as crying in the
with the chess engines that's what it's
all about this is it seems like it's
terrible it is
options right to counter attack correct
so more or less you're obligated to take
take and here you've got to
I think you've got to play Knight E6 I'm
going to play King D2 I'm not even going
to take on F5 and I'm just going to say
to you this is this is the position
that I really want I want to take and I
want to play B5 and again I have won so
many games as
the white position but sometimes you can
get the colors reversed right you can
also have this as a colors I've won this
position so many times without effort it
just like just putting the pawns forward
and and black doesn't really have to
make any mistakes to lose this position
so I really think that this is a bad bad
position but again I think the chess
engines are not going to agree with me
what about yourself well when I see what
you want to do it doesn't look nice
let's see the close-up of how the
players are the great think about this
position the graphics of these two
players so here we have Malik said who
as you know has been a many many many
time uh Captain yes of the US Women's
Olympic team or national team absolutely
and uh 23 of age Invitational already is
24.83 and he's the 1997 world team Chess
Championship bronze medalist and he's
tied for first coming into today's round
and his opponent Igor novikov germaster
yornovikov aged 61 Invitational rating
2562 and 1999 World open winner wow as I
said the world open was always a rite of
passage you had to just play the world
open just because uh
exactly uh jump in Christian uh What uh
what games have caught your eye it's all
about the Juniors it's all about the gym
really watching the Juniors because a
lot of things are happening this
theoretical battle between Josiah and
abhimani take a look at what happened in
this one yeah I think we left it after
them yes G4 and abhimani was spending a
lot of time trying to figure out the
intricacies and complexities of the
position and he chose to continue his
attack with the move A5 he's trying to
go A4 A3 weekend position for the white
king and take it from there and this
seems to have been perhaps something
that Josiah did not check in his
preparation because he did spend 15
minutes for his next move which was F4
the engines don't approve of that they
didn't like that at all no no it seems
like A4 was a golden opportunity
potentially for uh I'll be Manu to take
the reins in this game but it's not easy
I have to say I was looking through the
lines and it's really really dangerous
because white can go F5 right I'm going
to give you the Knight I'm going to take
on G6
and now rooked way to in fact is the
best move in the position very
counter-intuitive at least to my eyes
you are thinking about taking
potentially with a check B takes A2 but
Rook takes A2 and by the way F5 is also
a move I don't even want to calculate
this movement because if I manage to get
the queen on it I see that I see this
Pawn on G6 staying alive and I really
don't even consider this move exactly
G takes F7 and take a look at this not
Rook takes F7 because you need this Rook
to help your attack but King takes F7
this is completely wild stuff I take on
B3 now you go Queen to Aid if you miss a
single detail in your calculation with
both sides you might just be completely
losing right so now it seems like this
position
favors black but who knows objectively
with a better engine
um what's happening in the position for
example if you try to go for a piece
G5 right yeah good luck you're getting
checkmated next move right Rook to C8
this is problematic if you go Bishop to
C4 then I can continue Rook day C4 and
queen 24 and then Rook to A1 is going to
come in the position after Queen 24 the
game is over right so there's a lot of
things that you need to take into
account you're not getting to my king
while your king is getting checkmated he
spent a lot of time abhimanu and he took
on F4
Bishop to F4 and now it seems like white
once again has an objective Advantage
I'm still trying to figure out uh the
complexities of this position so I'll
get back with the analysis later on take
a look at this game though
Brandon Jacobson versus uh Kirk gazario
look at the times and it was much worse
just a few minutes ago 131 minutes for
Brandon Jacobson 48 minutes for Kirk
gazaria so he definitely got caught in
the opening and right now it seems like
objectively he's also much worse right
because White's plan is very easy with
the Knight on G3 this uh two Bishops
ready to put a lot of pressure on the
king side against the black king after
the move E4 I just feel like once I
managed to kick this Knight away maybe
even D5 E4 on sacrifice right open up
the bishop sacrifice the pawn take on F6
this Knight is landing on H5 after I
break your structure in front this is
not looking good guys yeah what is
really looking to attack the king side
and it's also about the time I mean
having to defend this position 40
minutes less than your opponent this is
not going this is going to spell trouble
for young Kirk gazer who had an amazing
start at this tournament yesterday a
brilliant Victory against Josiah sermon
but also Brandon Jacobson doing quite
well definitely coming into this
tournament with a great deal of
confidence absolutely as we're getting
into break territory it's a good time to
check in at our good friends at Q
Boutique and see what the specials are
for today and guess what we have a World
Chess Hall of Fame athletic jacket this
is the newest latest and greatest
Edition I want to say the World Chess
Hall of Fame jacket it is here and it is
not to be missed the jackets are 95
polyester and five percent Spandex and
feature an outstanding durable hot press
logo of the World Chess Hall of Fame on
the front available in men's and women's
style all your chess shopping needs
should be done Q Boutique St louis.com
and as we go into the break begin
she caught up with some of the players
and
well quiz them have a look
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Saint Louis it's nice to
see you here thank you yeah uh what are
you busy with these days am I busy with
these days yeah well besides chess
besides chess well I can't really tell
my competitors that but um I I've been
doing a bit of soul searching
um I haven't been home for
more than
you know a week at a time since what
February so I've been traveling quite a
bit and you know just exploring and
enjoying myself so it's been nice to
take a bit of the pressure off my
normally pretty fast-paced life yeah to
relax a bit
tournaments usually you play a lot of
tournaments and I can see whenever I
open like any American Events or there
yeah and then Han how you How do you see
your future as like do you see it as a
chess player professional chess player
or do you want to do something else
which is connected to your degree yeah
it's kind of hard to say I mean for now
I'm sort of trying to go along with both
and see and see how things go but for
now I'm enjoying chess and and seeing
where it goes so why not continue with
that awesome and it's your last year in
this tournament what are your
expectations
yeah you know it's kind of funny like
when I was younger I thought okay well I
have maybe what three or four more
chances to play this program I'm sure
I'll win one eventually but now I'm in
my last year and you know all these
young kids are passing me so it's tough
being the oldest but I don't really
think I have any expectations anymore I
think I'm just trying to have fun with
it and enjoy my last year here perfect
are you looking forward to play young
kids oh these young kids you know I
don't think anybody would say yes to
that question maybe you would
no I think whenever somebody comes to
the board and they see their opponent as
you know less than half their height
so we really started having panic
attacks
so I'm pretty sure that's a pretty
Universal answer yeah okay and
um do you expect to win the tournament
in general I know you said you don't
have any expectations but let's say as a
goal is that your goal or just to gain
some rating points well I mean okay I
think I'll be lying if I said my goal
wasn't to win the tournament but yeah I
think it's kind of tough to think but
especially because everybody's so close
and level I think it's mostly will come
down to who's in the best form
um
so it's kind of hard to say and I think
like if I had to guess the winner of the
tournament will only be at like plus
three or something so it won't be a
crazy margin so I think
it's it's really anybody's game
perfect and good luck thank you and good
luck with the tournament
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's Grandmaster
I will be doing social media for the U.S
Juniors and seniors chess championships
follow us in our social media and get
more exciting behind the scenes action
foreign
Louis chess club is the Premier chess
facility in the United States and is
among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
hello I am women's Grandmaster begin
Tucker jonoa I'm doing social media for
the US Juniors and seniors championships
here in San Luis follow us for more
exciting behind-the-scenes content
foreign
welcome hello welcome back to the studio
and let's look at the standings of us
girls junior we see Alice Lee Rochelle
Abu and Zoe tank all winning their first
round and tying for First with one point
and Karissa yeah
Rose Atwell having a half a point and in
the junior standings in the Juniors we
have five player tie for the first spot
with Brandon Jacobson abhimanyu Mishra
Andrew Hong Kirk gazarian and Arthur and
the legend and the legend in the Legends
we have Gregory kaidanov Alex shabalov
and Malik said catchy and winning their
first round tying for first while Igor
nodikov Maxim loogie Joel Benjamin and
Dmitry gorevich tying their first round
and time for fourth place so far
right and let's just uh jump into this
round two and I'm going to pick up the
game between Rose and Carissa and it
really feels to me like rose has made an
egregious error she's on the white side
of an open Sicilian and whenever I see
this pawns on B3 and C3 in a knight on
B1
especially if the bishop is not Beyond
shadowed inside
absolutely not so we we pick up around
these parts uh we haven't left uh too
much Queen E2 Rook D1 everything's fine
Bishop takes everything's fine and right
here something goes off the The Rails
with this move C3 I don't like this move
at all and after C3 there this actually
this a tactic and Carissa spotted it
right away uh the Spidey scent should be
tingling but this move really catches
white uh off guard the problem is the
simple Retreat Bishop E3 leaves the pawn
on e4 hanging you can go Bishop A5
Bishop A7 but what exactly
it looks very very weird your Bishop
just feels it like it's offside you can
go Bishop E7 castles one day you're
going to take this Pawn in the meanwhile
everything looks wrong for white so
Carissa looks good if we move back so
what do we play instead of C3 because
the pawn on C2 is attacked sure we are
Rook D2 I mean I agree you can play
Bishop B4 but then in that case I'm
playing C3 with the tempo I'm hitting
the pawn now if you play E5 I will
probably well I'm not sure I'm happy I'm
not sure I'm actually I'm not sure I'm
actually delighted right here with that
decision to play D4
um
maybe I'm I'm more inclined to play A4
at the moment and four is B4 maybe some
weak Square yeah so yeah uh somehow the
timing it just seems like Carissa was
faster on the C file than white was
ready to meet uh her here and this move
E5 is really throws white off completely
I wanted to go to the game of Rochelle
too by the way because I was more than
curious how Rochelle was going to win
her Pond back I'm a pond grab after all
maybe she did cast she did castle in the
long side and that was we were thinking
all of this stuff was forced Bishop to
D4
A6 Rochelle played A6 I thought it was
based on F6 but okay A6 takes takes F6
Bishop C5 and she still hasn't won her
fawnback she's still working hard she
used to figure out how to transfer one
of the knights right because we can play
urug d8 sure attack it but then we still
need a knight or we need to force the
bishop away maybe that is an option with
B6 move okay that's a check at the
moment so we have to I mean B6 uh okay
even if you force me at a certain moment
you still got to pay attention to the
um you could start with King D7 okay if
you like I don't know but the question
is is how are you going to get a knight
to E4 to to win this Pawn I have a
feeling that if you have to park your
Bishop on A3 it's going to be quite
passive and maybe my Knights can do
something let's say I just fall into
your whole scheme of
I mean again I'm just saying you're
right the bishop on A3 is not any great
shakes but
the longer that pond lives uh the less
Rochelle is going to like it well keep
an eye on this yeah and we're going to
throw it uh over to Christian to uh
clear our accomplice Christian what's
going on in this game and I think this
was the critical moment after she played
this move Bishop to D4 which by the way
is not one of the main lines not B
before is uh the main line in the
position uh Knight to D6 is also an
option Bishop to D4 not one of the
topical lines specifically because of
one reason and that is because black can
play the move F6 this is a crucial move
because it comes with a clear threat you
want to play the move E5 right right hit
that Bishop on D4 this was an important
move to make unfortunately she did not
see it and by the way black is not
necessarily taking over but black seems
to have equalized after this move F6 she
did not do that she played the move A6
but after Knight to D6 right now F6 is a
bit too late because I have this move
Bishop to C5 the pawn is no longer on A7
and that's is quite important because
with the phone on A7 I can stop this
move Bishop to C5 with the move B6
myself with the pawn on A6 that's not
possible because you're just simply
going to lose that pawn on A6 so there
is a slight differences my new details
that matter quite a lot in this one
that's the position we currently have on
the board still you know black is within
the range of potentially managing to get
enough compensation later on in the game
but the onus is definitely on her to
prove the compensation in this one I
have to say I like what Shreya has done
out of the opening right let's take a
look at what's happening in the junior
section guys because
a very interesting moment is right now
in this game between Andrew Hong and
Jason Liang and we were discussing about
this queen H6 followed by taking on G5
and the pitfalls that white could fall
into now let's see what can happen if
black is not attentive in this one and
this is the position he played the move
Queen to D3 he's not going for those
Queen to H6 lines right what is the most
natural move G4 thank you G4 is the most
natural move which loses on the spot yay
[Laughter]
you found it because after G4 Queen to
H7 it's resignation time we shave your
hands that's it there's nothing
Bishop to H6 is not good by the way
because I have a king here and I believe
I have some Knight King D7 all right you
get on your shoes well I'm getting out
right as fast as possible but I can trap
you and by the way these are moves that
you can definitely this is you know the
queen already left that side of the
board right you stop thinking about it
the queen is not coming back or even if
it comes maybe it's in a distant dream
right and you go you just play G4 right
happily very natural hey the queen comes
back into play and right now you can
resign so wow this is a pitfall that
Jason has to be very careful not to fall
into right now big big moment in this
one
and take a look at Josiah versus abimanu
Bishop takes F4 Knight to F6 the engines
were giving a tremendous Advantage after
the move Bishop to D3 for yazaya for
white yes wow just exchanged the bishop
and it seems like once you exchange this
bishop the king is going to be in deep
deep trouble
um I think that Bishop takes D3 at least
from a practical perspective it does say
the computer that is the best move I
don't like it at the same time if you
allow me to take on G6 and perhaps this
is the idea behind this move Bishop to
D3 let's say you go Rook to C8 it's a
bad move I can take a pawn but let's not
take that pawn for the moment I think I
can go 94 and 96 ideas once the pawn is
no longer on F7 and that creates some
significant
um unpleasantries for a black a on the
king side so Bishop to D3 big moment
right now and if you by the way if you
take and exchange the bishop the Bichon
G6 was protecting the king quite
um quite nicely unfortunately right now
on the G file you're going to have huge
huge problems Queen takes D3 if you pass
by with the move H4 I think this Knight
on F6 is going to get hit with uh G5 and
G6 open up the king you're not going to
be able to stop me and unfortunately I
think that it's going to lead to a
winning position for white so big moment
for ABI Manu for uh Josiah to get
playing this Advantage he missed it he
played the movie Bishop we have F3 but
one thing he's doing he's putting a lot
of pressure on ABI manu's clock
take a look at that one hour and 14
minutes for Josiah and only 40 minutes
for abhimanyu so that's okay Christian
story to interact yes they move H4
Bishop the last move right yeah
um
yes I think it's a good move well from a
practical perspective at least
what were you worried about
no no we were just saying that after the
move H4 by the way I like this movie
yeah it closes things up on the king
side but and that was quite afraid for
my king if I would have been in Black's
shoes and and you're right to be afraid
I I would be too uh but on the other
hand this move H5 H4 to my eyes
Christian it you know winning that E6
square that was like winning the lottery
right 1940s yeah but okay you can't get
to E6 because I'm not exchanging your
Bishop yes yes yeah but you sure can get
to the F5 Square so the move Knight D4
Knight F5 by the way yes I am thinking
about picking up the pawn on H4 how does
the engine assess the the current
position
the current slightly better for white
only slightly not as significant as in
the previous bishop to d33 that was a
significant Advantage I think it was
plus 1.7 close to plus two points
advantage that's significant okay um
this is only plus zero three so just a
slight Advantage but again from a
practical perspective I do feel like
there is some significant pressure uh
black is feeling right now after Knight
D4 very natural I I think Knight to E4
is the best move and I think this game
promises a lot of fights it does but
what if we go to the seniors we don't
spend that much time there sure there's
a very open position between Alex
shabalov and Gregory kaidanov let's
as both these two I want to say
youngsters
uh jump in uh to the round uh tied for
first they won their first game uh let's
see how they got here because remember
we had left it in this kg Joko piano
Knight A5 C5 and we left it just at
these parts and we were looking at
capturing twice on a D4 but Gregory said
you know what
it would be really nice to play a French
defense without the light Square Bishop
yeah like please do make my day play the
move E5 so I can play 94. shabala said I
want nothing to do with that I'll take
take take and now look look at this
pesky you know very very very nice
Gregory says you're welcome to it do you
want it no
that's a little bit of a surprise move
for me Knight D2 okay he wants to play
Knight to E4 cover his Pawn on F2 that's
a serious weakness
and Gregory said well you know what if
the Knight comes to E4 with the tempo
I'm not a happy camper a Play Bishop B4
and we've caught up with the players
your take on the position uh Kate it's
an extremely open position and I feel
black species are really well developed
the Rook on f file kind of targeting the
night hoping for F2 these two nights
this year was great it's the pieces
right yeah very active right I
understand there's a
so of course white is targeting this
Pawn very easily and happy to grab it at
any moment but maybe not too soon while
the Bishop on C1 is still not developed
right yeah I mean
you more or less you need to play like
moves like rookie 4 Knight C4 Bishop to
G5 and then start thinking about
grabbing the pawn but the active the
active black pieces for for the moment
really do make a good impression and I
would say it needs to be a little
careful you know we asked her what if I
just closed my eyes and capture that
pawn right now yeah you can do it you
can do it for sure but I'm thinking that
uh are you going to be really that happy
after a move like Knight F4 uh I don't
know I mean
feels like it I I'm giving up I'm giving
you the the chance to attack and I'd be
very reluctant personally but on the
other hand moves like rookie for Queenie
to do attract me
Black's not anxious to defend the pawn
on E6 it's almost like please take take
away my only weakness and and do your
work so
I'm thinking I prefer shabala's position
after rookie four but I would recognize
that I need to be careful and I need to
do it carefully uh the game that really
caught my eye is this game between Joe
Benjamin and Dimitri gurvich we left it
uh look what's happening G B5 G4 V4
yeah you almost feel like okay let's go
G5 no no I have to play Knight E2 now
after Knight E2 I mean to my way of
thinking I don't know you're going to
play E5 and Bishop E6 for sure or you're
going to play A5
Queen B5
that wow you know like we are not
worried about discover that yeah yeah I
mean that was a real uh surprise move
for me uh one one good point about the
move Queen B5 is it does
hold up the move G5 for a moment uh I'm
just I caught my eye I mean that's a
visual move you don't usually see
walking into a discovery how good or how
bad is this position because it's a very
sharp position indeed Christian
objectively is better for white yes it
is better for right but was this move
Queen B5 a good move it's a good move
yeah it is it's a very decent move yes I
don't think you have any big Discovery
ideas sure Knight F4 Knight G3 but where
is the Knight going afterwards right and
my plan is pretty clear as black I do
want to move my queen on the a file
somewhere right to create some potential
attacks against the A2 Pawn right maybe
after Queen 24 then I can start doing
battle to C8 kind of connect these
threats together right right I'm
threatening the pawn on A2 then I'm
looking at the pawn on C2 maybe Queen
goes back uh to C6 after I create some
structure imbalances maybe you will play
B3 at some point and then I go back and
go A5 A4 it's an interesting position
still sure why it might have a slight
Edge but anything can happen is very you
know it's a sicilian position it's a
typical Sicilian position in which
both sides have a lot of resources at
their disposal yeah I always like these
arguments uh I'm better no I'm better
well why are you better and you make a
really compelling argument well Michael
that was really good but so why do you
think you're better and then you make a
really compelling argument but I don't
see the argument here like how are we
going to continue with white Christian
because are we able to try for G5 or
prepare with Rook G1 exactly and that's
kind of the interesting side of things
in this position in fact what you want
to focus on right now is defense first
as white what do I mean by that you have
to start with King to B1 or at least
this is the recommendation and you are
looking at this type of ideas yes sure
so King to B1 may be natural
Rook to C8 but what about Knight C1 is
this natural as well kinda you need it
right but it is defensive yes you're
bringing another uh resource to the
queen side next to the King right but
this invites completely different type
of positions we're gonna go into the end
game that's going to be a completely
different discussion so right these are
the type of things that both of these
players will have to understand right
now and I have to say and I'm coming
back to this it's all about Temptation
what were you looking at F4 G5 trying to
break through trying to give the check
made right right against the black king
it's not that easy for example if you go
something like Rook to G1 the engine is
already saying black is better after the
move E5 or queen 2 A5 King to B1 and E5
right now followed by Bishop to E6 it's
all about the pressure on the pawn A2 so
a lot of things that still white has to
be worried about and uh this most likely
are the type of ideas that Joel right
now is calculating right yeah I remember
playing these positions for black and
sometimes like you can get worried that
white spawns are gonna like push through
and and just Checkmate you but on the
other hand you see that white king is
kind of you know without pieces around
so the C file is open the diagonal can
be tricky and it may be not that easy
for white to actually attack exactly uh
by the way the game between Igor novikov
and Malik said the game that I said you
know Igor you know is completely winning
like strategically for me it's over uh
Malik said kind of agreed essentially he
did play the move E5 the only break in
the center we can kind of fight for yeah
this is where I was saying you know beef
B5 I'm going to take I'm going to play
B4 I'm going to play B5 and I'm gonna
break uh that C6 pawn and I'm gonna get
a protected pass Pawn so E5 more or less
only move B4 please uh said Igor dude
capture so I'll recapture and I'll be
you know attacking the pawn on C6 I'll
be attacking the bishop on F5 nope
Knight E5 takes F6 wow a pawn sacrifice
because if you don't do this you know
I'll be playing moves like B take C6 and
I don't know even things like Rook A6
maybe even Bishop A6 so uh F7 F6 I
applaud uh not except for for for for
for doing this because if he just sits
back and lets white
stop stop digging your own grave no F6
is a big blunder big blunder huge
blunder no kidding I thought it was
almost four I know and this is why the
engines are no fun to work with because
they just tell you that it looks like
you open you are very happy to it makes
a lot of sense right right practically
visually it makes a lot of sense F6 is
completely losing after the move B takes
C6 B takes C6 followed by B5 you're just
simply not in time I'm the one breaking
your structure first I'm the one taking
the pawn on C6 taking the pawn on D5 and
leaving you with a even a weak King in
this end game so this is problematic so
F6 is a blunder the only move that
maintains the balance as uh black is A6
[Laughter]
it's all about stopping white from
playing B5 again that's why the engines
are so strong right right
um You probably don't want to take the
pawn on A6 I believe you will have some
problems after Bishop to D3 or 19 C7
you're replacing yourself on this pin
not a good idea maybe you can take with
a rook sure but again Rook takes A6
Bishop takes A6 maybe Rook to A8 Rook to
B8 also again you're a bit behind in
development right right and if I manage
to take the pawn on B4 Pawn on C5 is
going to fall after immediately as well
the Knight is stuck to defense of the
Pawn on E5 so you cannot move very well
this knight from F3 it does feel like
black is getting at least enough
conversation for the last Pawn probably
more than that so A6 big big opportunity
for uh maliksat to get back into the
game in fact perhaps even take over the
game after the move F6 if the natural
take on C6 followed by B5 comes on the
board then he's in trouble but Christian
sometimes when we are looking at this uh
variations do you think that they're
gonna recapture bags why do we captures
back he took on F6 yes because then
exactly I see playing this move d4
that's what I thought was the initial
idea exactly to open up the file and use
the king who is not canceled yet
attacked that King oh my goodness oh no
not even worse things are getting worse
like you so you're allowing e for long
Castle is winning for white right now
long love it wow that's that's a crazy
pin on that night that if he finds that
move that's that's a sick move right
there that is awesome that is good if
you take take and you know the moment I
play Bishop C4 you're crying yeah
I also want to go F7
castles long and that just turns the
tables because the whole idea is White's
King in the center vis-a-vis The Rook on
EA you you surely don't want to allow
any discover checks so I'm sure when
Alex said played the move d4 he had it
in his mind that he's the one pushing
saying he's the one with the initiative
castles is the cold shower that's that's
game over actually oh my God sometimes
in composition chess the correct move is
long castle and I hate that because like
all the pieces are pieces are cleared
from the board and you don't think about
castling so I think it's very easy to
miss that like your opponent can
actually still cast so what was it
composition and composition chair
sometimes yeah it studies yes you mean
yeah the way they compose and you make a
move like Castle yeah oh
oh a nasty move nasty move uh castles
long and Igor
how'd they get an advantage just five
plus five plus five is completely over
and if you don't see that castle you
play something else there are other
moves yes but it's white still much
better or B takes C6 is also winning but
not as conclusive also after B takes
easy you do have to follow up with
Castle either way you still have to do
castles right because if you see Castle
you might as well do it right now keep
the pressure as is yeah you know it was
funny because one of the original
thoughts I had was that after E4 D4 I
could play E4
the idea is like this bishop is kind of
like stuck of course if you take uh I I
shouldn't instantly
recapture but I was thinking that if you
take I would castle and two pieces are
hanging and like why don't I just Castle
immediately why do I need E4 castles
immediately that turns the table but by
the way yes okay Castle is obviously a
very flashy beautiful move but how
difficult is it to suggest not really
that difficult but just because uh this
Knight on D7 is hanging you always look
you P chess players have developed what
I want to call tactical awareness
sometimes you just show a strong player
a position and it's like they
immediately gravitate towards this idea
that well the piece is undefended and
even if the piece wasn't undefended if
you showed me this position one of the
first things I'm looking at is the fact
that this bishop could easily get
trapped so I start I start imagining A
variation where I go G4 F7 check 95
check right so uh what what I'm saying
is that I look at undefended pieces I
look at vulnerable Kings and I look at
pieces that could easily get themselves
trapped so how can I attack this Knight
on D7 oh I know
I play Bishop to B5 and Bishop takes
D7 you know just how do I attack it how
do I attack the Knight on D oh I know I
play Rook D1 Rook takes a t7
though I mean obviously I have obstacles
but right those are the that that that's
my mindset that's my pattern that I'm
thinking how do I attack undefended
pieces so for me when I see the move d4
I do see Rook D1 with D7 how about
yourself
you develop that in that you develop
that awareness yeah and I always look
also for like the Alternatives and here
just moving the Knight doesn't really
look good capturing looks absolutely
disastrous yeah yeah it captures and it
captures and Retreats are not not the
things you want to do right so I think
really Igor is here thinking whether to
capture on C6 first or whether to Castle
right I think those are the only two
moves he's actually considering the
other move that you always look at too
in these types of positions or is it
more like Bishop C4 because of course
you know I understand it's coming at
this terrible cost of the night but
those kind of uh
um uh absolute pins you know you love
those absolute pins so sometimes you
think I I can sacrifice to get an
absolute pin but I'm thinking Castle's
coming uh by the way just want to go
around the horn very quickly this was
the game we looked at earlier kaidana
who likes being on the attack by the way
he's the one
I want to interrupt myself because
tactical awareness you know you you
start to think
takes right
and the old double attack right because
and then you you stop because you're
like okay
there is a defense because otherwise you
know like you're wait a minute the the
bishop on B4 suddenly you know you're
tactical your spidey sense is tingling
you know there it is okay there's that
one we haven't seen Max delugie and
Patrick Wolfe so what a phone structure
seriously right
you know you almost got a chair Patrick
Wolf when you look at that position you
say to yourself what a safe King and
look at if I Bishop takes a five if I
capture that Bishop triple pawns no I'm
not gonna catch a vision capture the
night uh
well are you gonna capture tonight
sure I have to I just even even thinking
about capturing the bishop is an effect
at an ethma to me no I I can't capture
the picture but then you're going to be
pulled down right okay but yeah this
isn't there divert my eyes I don't want
to even imagine how horrifying uh my
long-term prospects are get out of here
no it looks like Maxim is winning
um a pawn takes takes how to recapture
we can capture with a bishop or a pawn
bishop probably Pawn well okay Queen d4m
still well I want to say kicking right
I mean okay that's a powerful level
attack yes exactly it's fine yeah again
it's this sense that I'm drawn to
whatever is undefended yeah in the
position F4 B2 undefended uh Vladimir
kopian that was the Douglas root game
Wow 85 trying to break in on the king
side
we left it he did win The Exchange
how do you feel about that King on G8
not good
I'm losing my dignity I mean I don't
have my Pawn Shield where's my Pawn
Shield not but it will take some time
for white to get the rook in to play
that is true but okay Knight F4 in the
long term prospects uh don't look that
good for Douglas uh Igor novikov we've
already talked about castles and I'm
going to toss it over to you Christian
what has caught your eye well let's stay
within the silly complexes of the French
structures right with the naked King
You've seen that one in that game that
you just showed but this one Jason Liang
didn't fall for that G4 trap no so
that's good news for him but he did play
the move Queen to E8 take on a G5 take
on G5 this is the position the rules
have sort of reversed for Jason because
he was viciously attacked on the H file
Yesterday by Brandon you remember that
the queen landed on H shade with rock on
H5 the battery on the H5 was very
dangerous and it actually was decisive
but right now he has to worry about
Queen to H5 while he actually will be
probably delivering Queen to H5 followed
by Rook to h8
um attacking ideas the problem is I have
this light on C3 which will help my
defense tremendously so you have to be
careful how you're going to employ those
tactical resources as black this is the
position proudly Bishop to detour Bishop
to E3 and then comes the question do you
go for the end game with Queen to G6 or
do you go for the attack with Queen to
H5 it does seem like Queen to H5 if you
understand that this Knight after Knight
to E2 Rook to h8 Knight to G3 comes with
Tempo not only that but you have
everything protected on the king side
around the white king you're kind of in
trouble because you deployed so many
resources and you left behind the pawn
on G5 The Rook is no longer defending
that the king is kind of weak you don't
have a clear way to uh exchange the
Queens anymore Queen to G6 is no longer
possible you have to stay connected to
the pawn on G5 it just seems like right
now black species are not on their
optimal squares and white is taking over
and that's the case so after Bishop to
D2 or Bishop to E3 Queen 2 G6 seems to
be the main move but I have to say I'm
looking at the position I'm seeing
knightway for this Knight is starting to
linger around the queen side it just
feels unpleasant for black it feels like
I have too many weaknesses in it I'm not
going to be able to defend all of them
B6 Square after the exchange of the
Queens the pawn on G5 as well the E5
Square it just seems like there's too
many weaknesses and I still have to
develop my pieces the bishopon C8 very
difficult to get it out right now
because I have to deal with the move
Knight to B6 so I still see white as
being in the driver's seat in this one
and in that game the one between Josiah
and abimani well something things have
happened we've seen after the move H4
rook he1 and abimani started pushing his
Pawn a494 A3 B3 and this is the position
we currently have on the board
it's all about practicality right now
forget about the engine eval who do you
guys think
stands back who has the easier position
either for for me I love the Harmony in
White's position I mean the Rooks are in
the center the board the the minor
pieces are looking great this night on
D4
especially kind of an All-Star ready to
jump to the F5 Square I think it's
easier to play
why I do think however the imbalances of
the position the Kings on opposite
flanks always
allows for
counter capture Spiel yeah but I like
the harmony I agree with you after and
we see the king is kind of safe with
that black bone on A3 stopping the The
Rook from attacking the king and
obviously really well the position and
it can be white who may decide to you
know continue attacking on the e-file or
slowly start pushing on the king side by
the way this close-up visual of the
games these pieces are so nice yeah
they're from the house of starting the
triple weighted hand carved luxury sets
dgt enabled you sit there and you play
with them at the board
light on the ball I know the slide so
much to play with them I know yeah that
looks like it's from the Rochelle uh
shell game I feel I feel like it's time
to go to the girls exactly I wanted to
turn to the game of Rue Yang Yan and
Alice Lee remember Alice Lee sacrificed
upon earlier in the game in this Russian
defense and she did it with the move C5
by the way which I felt you know it kind
of goes to show she's up to date on the
latest news that was Christian's
recommendation exactly the latest and
greatest in uh opening Theory Knight C6
and uh rouyang felt that if you know if
she played D3 then Bishop Bishop 96 and
Bishop D4 so she felt compelled to go
for the D4 break but at the same time
Alice now has recaptured her upon Alice
is saying okay if you let me castle and
play Bishop F6 I'll be fighting for uh
the advantage so let's take a look at
what happens for example I
I don't know should I call him Knight C3
first for me 93 is very natural plus
Bishop E3 is a threat exactly castles
Bishop E3 right more or less more or
less we could kind of
expect or count on this uh going in this
direction Queen F6 so I want to invite
the trade or I want to double your pawns
now you can you could win them
you can win the minor Exchange
this is what uh Bobby Fischer would call
the Bishop versus knight a minor
exchange with pawns on both planks the
double pawns the messed up bone
structure is something that's maybe
balanced but maybe not what white wants
right so I don't know you could have
also played Rook D1
so if you've played Rook D1 in this
position and after for example the same
line queen of six a slight difference
here is there's no double pawn and you
might be asking uh black I'd like to
return the favor to you Bishop on C1
that is guarding the V2 Pawn exactly but
okay if I move let's say Bishop more or
less you don't really have a better move
than developing it feels very balanced
is what I'm saying in this one I want to
go to the game of Carissa yep because
when we left it we thought that Rose had
messed up that move E5 was the cold
shower move that just basically said to
White your whole concept with BC B3 and
C3 wrong and after Bishop E3 well
Carissa just snipped the pawn and said
hey I'm upon up do your worst and I've
got the two Bishops and uh Carissa looks
like she's in Cruise mode right now as
uh no question about the advantage here
for black pulling up where's the
conversation right that's what I'm
asking and G2 by the way you know I'm
not you know when I take those pawns
that are protecting your king those are
really really really good pawns to be
held so it looks like Carissa is uh in
charge maybe some like Rook A7 trying to
attack guide on D7 and that at least uh
I am still terrified of the pair of
Bishops and my knight on B1 being like
kind of still attacked right but at
least I'm trying to to counter-attack
you I like that move uh it's it's it's
it's it's it's challenging uh I'm just
pause for a moment because I'm I'm
actually looking should I be playing
Bishop not with the idea of winning the
pawn just with the idea of distracting
the rook and just saying or am I am I
scared of you taking this Pawn I'm not
even sure should I be afraid like Rook
takes be afraid be afraid always be
afraid I am happy to capture my night I
feel like that's something I would
welcome right the bishop is dangerous on
that diagonal if you don't take my
knight
yeah I'm just wondering what would be uh
you know Bishop D6 feels a little bit
unnatural
a little bit okay just just okay let's
just show me what you're doing gonna do
Bishop I I'll call you Bluff yeah it's a
bluff I agree I'll call your block of
course it takes you too I want to play
Bishop F3 and on a good day Queen G6
check
and I'm worried about maybe some even
like Bishop H1 and then wanting to
Checkmate me on G2 oh I wouldn't do that
type of thing you're a very nice person
that's not a fate you're deserving of
unless unless you play unless it's
really good
so I would like to capture on D7 but if
I capture let's say Rook this one you
have Bishop H3 all right oh no I think
I'm gonna go Queen G6
but your Bishop H3 also Bishop anywhere
right now yeah that that's a little
discouraging right because I mean that
Queen G6 check is uh and queen G2 oh
everything is deadly guys yeah Bishop
hits G2 okay Rook A7 just not in the
cards and let's see
Zoe because that is right you know we
are talking about attacking positions
sure let's just see the faces of navikov
and medicine because did he play the
castle he did he did play castle so I
want to see the expression of the magic
of Television can we get uh
get the look of Malik set after the move
castles it must be a cold shower for him
oh yeah you know because uh oh hold on
let me just bring up that game apologies
I'm a little bit behind on the on the uh
so no capturing on C6 immediately
castling so so the point was Black's
last move was this very attractive
looking move D5 D4 The Rook on E8
vis-a-vis the King on E1 you're
attacking the Knight on C3 when you play
the move d4 you have it in your body
language your your mindset I'm the one
with the initiative
you are in trouble what are you gonna do
and your opponent says well on guard you
go
oh
I think I missed that I think I missed
that one because now The Rook it turns
the tables uh yes I understood that I
was in a pin on the e-file but now
there's no pin on the e-file and in fact
I have a pin on the D file you take my
knight you're welcome I'll take your
knight don't forget about F7 check don't
forget about Rook takes B7 Bishop C4 I
mean there's a lot of things you
shouldn't forget about but and here we
have Igor on the white side he seems to
be happy but uh I I think I would be a
lot happier it's almost
kind of a stone face expressions I can't
read how I mean it doesn't know how good
it is yeah that's that I would think
castles is really good I mean and I
think on the other side of the board now
like I said he's looking at he goes oh
yeah Malik is starting to understand
that this is what am I going to do now I
mean yeah I can take this Pawn on C5 I
can play Knight takes C5 Pawn take C5 I
don't think I have to take on C5 oh you
don't even have to take them I think I
can take on D4 actually just simple with
the Knight maybe with the knife sorry
one thing is if I take with the Knight I
think I'm opening up
um that a2ga diagonal as well also so
something today now I'm going to take on
C5 I think
I can never guess what uh moves maybe
I'm getting too fancy okay you know what
I'm getting too fancy and I take C5 you
still have this Pawn on that's I mean
you might just be winning after G4 or
Bishop C4 check yeah but I feel it's too
fancy
we can always block on E6 right what
recovering yeah what do you mean
recovering like what do you want to do
with white I want to go G4 I don't see
how you're recovering I think I'm
getting I think I'm going to get killed
all right I take take
no but you guys are right this is not
good no yeah
not that good for a white nothing I want
something better okay so anyway once you
take on D4 I take back with the pawn uh
well I I think taking on C3 is just a
full disaster right I think I have to do
a move like Knight takes C5 to mix
things up completely agree yeah okay so
how do I take on D4 and then you take
back on D4 I take back on D4 with the
pawn
did you want to take on D4 with the
Knight
you choose you choose I think both of
them have the same impact more or less
okay Kate you got to decide it's so
complicated so many things are hanging
hey that's why you get the big bucks
come on let's capture with the Knight
but you know what the thing is about
this type of positions what we forget
that white is two points out correct
because you know pieces are flying pawns
are flying left and right for for both
sides right but at the end of everything
white is just simply going through two I
love capturing with a pawn by the way
because you your knight can't move if it
goes to E4 this is what uh I was always
thinking about you know with these
phones oh I mean it's just like yikes
right
and that diagonal and
yeah no this this is bad uh let's go to
the Juniors to the girls to the girls I
want to see Gracie against Zoe tanks
it's such a interesting position because
we are going here like left and right
capturing and kings on the opposite side
and here we have a positional actual
um
taking weaknesses
by the way that's a long easy game uh
Knight A4 okay uh eyeballing the C5
Square opening up the C file so that's
on C6 on the other hand this Knight on
D5
nicely positioned
no not so nicely positioned as black is
targeting the pawn on B6
uh any trades on no you can't take on C6
if you take on C6 Knight A4 and Bishop
t7
okay Bishop E5
Bishop to G5 hitting
almost capturing realizing you can't
really capture the pawn because it's the
same thing happening if you take on C6
you walk into a nasty nasty skewer yeah
or that will cost an exchange
so by the way Rook C5 Bishop E7 takes
takes
Zoe so one there was a chance for
repetition right right but black didn't
want that right so somehow just a second
where did Zoe win a pawn
so no
no she hasn't won a pawn
it almost feels like
she's avoiding a repetition right so
that was like a quiet offer of a draw if
black wanted to go back Bishop G5 and
Zoe wasn't interested
although what's your take on the
position that's the thing the phone on
C6 is kind of weak and I'm not sure if
you are if you will be able to push for
C5
right well the only way you can do that
is you've got to protect the bishop so
it seems to me if anything your your
plan is black has got to be based on
what you've just said Queen B6 and C5 so
if I'm true to form and I do believe in
you know putting as much pressure on the
C6 Bond as possible I would go Rook C2
Rook C2 very natural move just double up
the Rooks yeah
they called me Mr Natural
Rook C2 co-colors of Mississippi it's
from the underground comics of the of
the Bay Area Mr Natural
I mean can we do something like Bishop
A6 to attack the rook and transfer the
bishop to B5 that's a more positive
thinking yeah the bishop on B7 was the
passive yes Bishop on B5 will at least
be
um well aggressive right but I'm also
helping kind of for white to get its
pieces where she wants to have them
through that true that if I could by the
way the queen on A4 in my mind if I
could get the queen on G3 or H5
something there you know I would be a
happy camper so yeah you
you know Bobby Fischer famously said to
get squares you got to give them and in
this case it's sort of like black got a
more active piece but so did white so
you get you know you give and take and
what is this push A4 right forcing the
bishop to go back yeah I was almost
thinking that you have to stop me from
playing A4 myself and we'll get a
position like this
I don't know uh I'm balanced I probably
the engines are going to go triple zero
but we know that it's actually a really
big fight taking place in this game
um Christian uh clear the cobwebs yes in
this position
um I believe Zoe had to take the draw
with Bishop G5 uh the one repetition
offer earlier by white Bishop B7 Bishop
G5 Rook C1 Rook C5 right now it does
seem like she's much much worse of
course the engine is saying that this is
border like Lucy plus 1.2 hovering
around 1.2 1.5 for white so it's all
about the weaknesses right you have so
many of them as black pony A5
specifically the pawn on C6 that I will
be able to Target quite easily I'm going
to double up on the C file and at some
point this one is going to fall you
would love to have this bishop on D5
right unfortunately that's not possible
right that's not a chess works if you
would be able to fly this bishop on D5
your position fine because I don't have
from where to attack the pawn on C6 with
my Bishop on F3 right there's no way to
put it there's no configuration on the
board that will attack the pawn on C6
directly so Bishop B7 terrible piece if
you would be able to get it on D5 that
would be fine without that you're just
much much worse so this one is
problematic but take a look at what's
happening in uh the Juniors section
because Josiah has increased
tremendously his Advantage so right now
we left it after B3 and we were
discussing the engine was in fact saying
0.3 not a significant Advantage by any
means very complex position but from a
practical perspective it just felt like
it's so much more easier to play with
white right and that's exactly what
happened Knight to D7 already a step in
the wrong direction because you allow me
Bishop to E4 and we've been trying to
exchange these Bishops for so many moves
right right that Bishop to D3 that was
the missed opportunity right now finally
I have once again the opportunity to
exchange one of your biggest Defender
and maybe even attacker right because
this Pawn on C2 if you put something I
work on the C file with a couple with
the action of the Bichon G6 you will
have some problems on C2 so Bishop to E4
Josiah takes his uh chance take take
Knight to C5 and now Rook to E2
23 minutes keep an eye on this because
this is significant this is only move 26
Still 14 moves very difficult 14 moves
for uh ABI Mania and right now the
pressure is all on black because Knight
F5 is coming right G5 potentially is
coming G5 G6 that's an idea as well try
to uh force you to give me the E6 square
and the question is where is your attack
how do you continue your attack as black
you have to do something it's in our
nature
to try to do something but you just
simply I I at least I don't see the
active plan for black in this position
you try to go Bishop F6 to put the
bishop on the long diagonal G5 is coming
right yes so how how do you continue and
we can see abhimanyu Mishra she's he's
slow on time right he has 20 minutes
while uh Josiah Stillman has around 4 58
minutes actually one hour so a big time
difference and again the position is
he did Play Bishop F6 because again like
you said you don't want to be in a
position where you're just passively
awaiting your fate you know Knight F5
and Bishop F6 by the way that's uh a
No-No you don't do that so Mishra just
played the move Bishop F6 you pressed
his clock he wrote it down on the score
sheet then he realized that he hadn't
put his Bishop in the center and he
reached and he just on his opponent's
time you don't do that by the way guys
yeah allowed to do that go this is plus
four right now after G5 no Knight F5
apparently neither five hitting the pawn
on D6 best move and then I'm assuming
Mishra wanted to play Rook A6 just to
defend the pawn in fact G5 is one way to
lose a big chunk of your advantage wow
because that's something you want to do
right you want to chase that Bishop you
do yeah so Knight F5 Rook A6 now I go G5
where do you put the bishop I was going
to put it on beat
I know it looks a little funny but I
just don't have a square on the diagonal
I completely agree I know it's it's all
about finding a way to check my deal 97.
oh no and Queenie won exactly oh that's
a puzzle Rush tag this is really bad
news oh my word this is really really
bad news that's over over over
uh sorry after the move Knight F5 did I
blunder Rook A6 after the move Knight to
five the position is just really bad
it's just really bad you have to do
things such as Rook to E8 right now give
up the D6 pawn and pray that you will
get something at some point but that's
very hard to do to give up the pawn on
D6 allow the D5 Pawn to be passed and
just well the problem is is that G5 is
is crunchy yeah just absolutely
devastating okay guys let's think about
the practical ways in which black can
play this yeah the only thing I see is
Knight A4
Knight A4 okay I think this is what he
wants so if we take Queen B6 he's made
right and it's just a stone cold mate
okay so that's what he's thinking I I
think so he must be thinking about this
so I have to it it feels like I I should
stop Knight C3 check lucky three yes
not only that but actually right now
you're threatening to take on A4 now
you're right now I can meet Queen B6
check with Rook B3 so that's a problem
yeah
G5 is a threat as well so this might
just be a Tempo loss for black because
you probably have to go Batman I mean at
first when you suggested the move Knight
A4 I thought yeah right fighting back
you know not not awaiting the cruelty of
your fate but Knight A4 Rook E3 is a is
a cold shower move okay so this bishop
F6 is a semi Bluff from abhimani right
now what should he have played G6
uh to stop now it's it's difficult it's
really difficult rookie eight is the
best move but Bishop f8
not yet at least right
it's just such an uncomfortable position
you have to go Queen D7 and then you
will go beach by Fate maybe at some
point but this is just taking a very
passive approach to your defense right
Bishop uh yeah Bishop F6 Knight F5 and
um
Josiah I want to say yes he's in the
driver's seat Kate what what game has
caught your eye I want to go back to the
girls juniors yes because there's one
game we did not spend much time on yes
the youngest uh together with Alice
League player in the 13 years old
incredible the winner of the 2022
um Casper of just Foundation all girls
National wow Championship so Irish small
against kelsilu what is happening here a
lot of pieces on the board it has that
Minority attack uh I want to say
um
Karo Khan type of positions that I would
get as black Rook a C8 okay that's a
little of a of a surprise move for me
okay defends the Knight the queen looks
like almost trapped right this is I you
know if I was an iris's shoes I would
probably be tempted by a b because after
all I do have the a files she played
Rook C1 which is a surprise Queen East
seven and we've caught up with the
player's Cape your take what's going on
it's not that easy to
easy to to to a judge yeah I feel like
black would like to maybe take on C3
with the pawn to make another weakness
and then capture on A3 with the bishop
but the bishop is still guarding the
Knight on F4 right so we cannot just do
that so it's not like this is a threat
but the question I would have is what
should white be doing I mean I feel like
in such positions I need to play the
move Knight E5 uh so the the problem I'm
having it's a timing issue right in 95
immediately Bishop takes E5 and I feel
like Black's the first
well black will win material after
Knight E2 check and I don't want that so
I can't play Knight E5 give me a
suggestion for black for for white I'm
sorry
I mean one possibility is to play H3
right just kick the bishop away okay the
bishop there is stays annoying let's say
it keeps an eye on the F3 Knight
stays annoying maybe like Queen B5 like
quiet move just improving the queen okay
Queen B5
the old quiet move improving the queen
routine
aha uh I do like what you were saying
there a moment ago about takes takes I
agree that this is not what I want but
I'm looking at Knight A7 and
trying to um
well give me another Pawn on A5
yeah I if I'm
I understand that when Kelsey played
Queen E7 she had it in her mind that she
would like to play Queen F6 so that she
has Knight H3 ideas so I'm I'm gonna try
to channel my Inner Health are you sure
you're not going to lose the queen
Oh no you're a queen oh no oh no I I
stepped into a a foul
oh boy I sure did no no the queen things
don't go there no no no no Queen F6 okay
um that leaves me kind of with short of
breath I'll go H6 just asking you to
play it's not easy this is this is a
this is a awkward position I think both
players what are the clock Times by the
way so we see Kelsey has 36 minutes and
Iris was playing white has 28. so more
or less more or less same yeah slight
Advantage for Kelsey but now it's iris's
turn to make and yeah we'll see uh just
turning again to our favorites in the uh
girls competition and the game of Alice
Lee we did see Knight C3 Rook d8 by
Alice Bishop E3 Queen F6 and they're
going into those lines uh that we were
looking at with Queen F6 it seems very
very balanced to uh my eyes at least
Carissa by the way Carissa didn't like
after F3 she didn't like the fact that
she was a little bit behind in
development she decided to capture the
Knight on B1 Bishop takes B1 and she's
cruising she's she's a pawn up Bishop C5
development and uh yes exactly and as
soon as she Castle she's going to be
doing great one player is not doing
great as Rochelle when we left it she'd
actually
um well I mean she had sacrificed a pawn
and was trying to win it back the move
G3 got this position and yeah she just
said Hey look
at least she's gonna try to go for that
exactly I mean and in this position she
can fight I mean because again the
Bishops of opposite color but if that
pawn stays on the board yeah forever you
just lose so uh she made the right
practical decision over to you Christian
and why does caught your eye well Josiah
did make a mistake so he played the very
natural G5 that we were discussing sure
G5 but unfortunately after Bishop D4
which came instantaneously right because
there's no choice there's nothing else
you can do right yeah give me that night
of course get out of here but right now
you have this uh idea for and you have
to do it F5 or F6 one of the two F5 is
much more aggressive because it forces
matters now right now I have a pretty
significant threat and that is to place
my knight on e4 right you don't want to
see that Knight land on e4 that's
probably going to uh mandate the um
sacrifice of an exchange with C4 so
that's not really what you want as white
but what you can do is take and go into
this end game
it's not the same Advantage though this
is not the same thing you have a couple
of moves ago sure maybe you still have a
slight Advantage but at night on C5
ready to jump to E4 get to C3 if
possible I have the G Pawn which could
potentially become very very dangerous
later on it's not the same Advantage you
had a few moves ago so perhaps after F5
the tables are slowly turning into
abhimani's favor and also given that
he's uh down so much time he wants he's
inviting this type of simplified
positions right and that's what I think
he's going to go for either F6 or F5 you
have to do something you have to stop my
attack on the king side as black the way
to do that is with F6 or F5 let's see
what he does as we're getting prepared
for a break I just want to say once
again for those of you who are joining
this light thank you for joining us and
sharing your day uh you can join the
conversation you know how to do that but
really I wanted to give a shout out to
our
yeah this is how you can join the
conversation hashtag is at St Louis
chess though but we've got this
beautiful graphic of pagan yeah comment
on YouTube twitch Twitter Instagram
Facebook leave us a comment ask a
question there you go here we go beg him
happy birthday we are so happy to have
you here indeed we are and we're going
to take a break uh we'll see you on the
other side of this break for round two
of the national championships see you
soon
[Music]
hello Malek it's lovely to see you back
in Saint Louis and it's in general
lovely to see you
so as a captain of our Women's National
Chess team do you feel like you need to
play tournaments to feel don't to not
lose the feeling of a player yes
absolutely you know that I always
thought in order for me to kind of
provide high quality service
particularly for U.S national team I
thought I need to have some still
practical strength and that's the reason
why I'm still pushing myself even so I
don't have much time I can be occupied
with lessons but still I suppose I have
a window I'm jumping on it and I'm
trying to play some tournaments make
sure I can still keep my kind of
strength on it you know absolutely and
you got a wild card for this tournament
what does it mean to you honestly didn't
realize it's wild card but sure when
Alex told me that by the way it's like a
few minutes ago
I'm sure I was surprised I was shocked
but uh I checked my emails always
frequently and as soon as I saw like
email from Saint Louis I like jumped
from the chair I said oh my gosh really
this is what I was playing for the
funniest part I began so I get some
invitations to play in some tournaments
but always reply to my you know friends
saying listen I'm hoping to qualify for
U.S sinner I'm hoping to cooperate for
you sooner because for me the Saint
Louis as destination always considered
as a top priority so I was hoping for it
and I guess got so you manifested it
pretty much yeah that is awesome it's
it's see you playing as well for me
because you usually uh you were our
captain for the Olympiad as well and
usually you just you know help us with
the tournament and I'm happy to see you
suffering a little bit as well as a
chess player and what are your
expectations around the tournament
honestly I'm here to play chess
I think two years ago of the pandemic
when I came here I had a high
expectation I thought I'm ready to fight
uh for the you know high place blah blah
blah so I got lost place
after that though I'm happy you know
it's like I found a piece right yeah
that's affected my to my kids I said so
Daddy goes to the tournaments nothing
goes will happen it only happened two
years ago so this time it's going to be
fun right and I'm just here to play
chess and I'll do my best so we'll see
awesome and last question for you
how do you handle to be a captain in
general like just sit there and see your
team and then your you have great
students as well as a coach to see how
they are playing do you get a feeling
you just want to sit instead of them and
just make moves
it's it's it's yeah you you nail it um
basically This Is My Philosophy that's
what I believe
I'm kind of sacking all this negative
energy
and I'm reversing it to negative I mean
to positive and I'm sending my wives to
my girls to you to everyone and I think
it works it worked in uh you know in
Chennai when we remember when I said the
other day I said believe it we're going
to win five rounds and we're going to
qualify and at the end of the day we're
going to be playing on the stage yes
remember this conversation I did and we
did it and it was a fantastic call to
make you play in the first board and the
serve I mean I was worried in the
beginning but then I kind of got used to
it you know honestly when we're playing
against India I knew you're going to be
handling this easily somehow we had to
just start doing that earlier right my
first years of being Capitan uh it was
tough but then I can learn you know I'm
learning from a learning I'm learning
but these days I'm I was like a
experienced Capital so I know because
it's also important when Capitan is
nervous it's actually affecting on the
girls so you gotta learn this as well
sounds great Malik it's lovely to see
here again and I love your positive
energy I love having you around and good
luck with the tournament I will be
rooting for you thank you thank you
thank you appreciate it
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's current Master William
takor jonova I will be doing social
media for the U.S Juniors and seniors
chess championships follow us in our
social media and get more exciting
behind the scenes action
foreign
chess club is the Premier chess facility
in the United States and is among the
best in the world thanks to co-founders
Dr Jeannie Karen singfield and Rex
sinkfield the St Louis chess club is a
non-profit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomed
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
thank you
hello everyone and welcome back to our
show these are the standings after round
one Kate U.S girls junior Alice Lee
Rochelle and Zoe Tang have one point
after the first round then we have
karisay ruyengien Kelsey Liu and Rose
Atwell with half a point and in the
junior section we had five decisive
games
five-way tie for the first place Brandon
Jacobson abimano Mishra Andrew Hong
kirikazarian and Arturo all tying for
the first place exactly and in the as
seniors we have the veterans yes let's
take a look at their standings we have
Gregory kaidanov Alex shabalov and
Medics at katyan with one point and Igor
novikov Maxim loogie Joel Benjamin
edmitry grevich with half a point and we
do have a result and in the uh game
between I want to say our Marquee
matchup of two
um leaders between shavalov and Gregory
we have a blunder uh by Alex shibalov
and he has overlooked in this position
remember it was that pawn sacrifice yeah
E6 closing eyes very yeah very
unpleasant and
um Shabba just missed a tactic he played
the move Knight on D2 to F1 and it's
almost like a puzzle Rush type of thing
you play the move Rook takes F3
you go g takes F3 and you say okay so
where's the tactic here and your eye
should be drawn to the fact that the
king is exposed and there's a check
there's a check on the G5 script no
there's not because the bishop covers
the G5 let's eliminate the bishop and
then suddenly it's very clear you losing
a a too much material Rook takes Queen
G5 check and whoops excuse me my pick
to win the tournament had to resign so
we get rid of the defender and then we
make a double
attacked a single result Gregory kaidana
moves let's clear first quickly go
through a copy on a route because I
think that one is just about to finish
as well uh Vladimir copian versus
Douglas root because yeah this was the
one where well it was all about uh
Doug's King frankly was exposed now the
smooth Queen G5 check you're looking at
Queen d8 check and The Rook is going to
capture the queen
this looks just about to be resignation
time absolutely and again that's uh with
a an older position on the board on the
analysis board
this is what has happened check and yeah
yeah this D5 move let's take a look
slowly on that because that's a really
nice start of the tactic and so easy to
miss
well there was this move Knight f42 so
rookie you got 1965.
night before now you cannot capture that
line because similarly to that shabal of
Kaiden of days we have this double
attacks I was about to say it's that G5
square and the exposed King I mean it's
almost uh we could make a tactical book
on the U.S championships and I think
this was the move and now D5 right
before that's an incredible move super
strong clearing the e-file with a gain
of tempo so that I have to take check
now we're ready to introduce the Rook so
for example if we move our King that
that makes it so easy this is the whole
concept of the move D5 clearing the
e-file so we get to play Rook to E7
wow so if you go Queen I guess Queen G6
might be the only way to to hang in
something yeah uh Rook check how do we
finish the game right now right how
should we finish so Rook Chuck I have to
go King G7 King F7 guess checkmated
so just a second so Rook checking
G7 yeah yes Queen Jack King H6 King H6 I
don't have
my Rook E6 okay just a second sorry
you're making my you're making me work
maybe I have to do it this way yes what
do you think about the queen of Faith
yes
E7 yes
and at some point I'm still going to pin
that queer yeah that Rook one way or
another either on the E file or on the G
file Gonna Get You
you gotta get you uh nice uh there so we
do and what about uh I it was rather
funny what uh bacon was saying in that
interview with Malik said he said he'd
come to the senior championships full of
ambition I'm gonna be on the podium took
that last
night
nice and he started very well right he
won the first round made an upset
against the number one seed absolutely
but unfortunately for him
he's down uh two pawns and unfortunately
uh Igor is the one who is on the attack
at the moment we can see clearly that
Knight E7 check is uh going to really be
hurtful as well so
um
good good things are happening for Igor
this guy and remember Igor yesterday he
saved a completely losing position and
he hung on it was a grim defense against
Dima Dimitri gurvich Dima I thought was
going to win it for the longest time so
that was a victory
Igor has to be careful about here
here to get to the 40th move
right that's something that he has to be
careful about to make sure he's playing
moves fast for some reason the uh the
board there that we're showing that's
not the live position the analysis
position
is actually the light position so we
just have to update our boards there
um Joe Benjamin Dimitri gurvich that was
a game that that the two players that
were busily attacking one another's
Kings but somehow when the Queens left
the board so did the excitement and it
kind of like died down a little but is
it flaring anew
I mean white has
quite I want to say a positional grip
um there was a the worst chess book ever
I mean I think it's it it it's a contest
right I mean because there's some really
really bad books but Pawn power and
chess by Hans kamak uh has to be right
up there because he tried to label every
kind of Pawn structure with some
ridiculous thing like the the
underhanded grip you know like really
what does that mean I don't even know
what it means but this is a this is just
not tennis a pond structure yeah the
Continental grip there you go are you
using the Continental ring uh this grip
he called this a kind of grip and in
fact it is in this particular case the
night on age seven really makes a bad
impression like it has no where to move
conversely White's looking great if he
just gets to play Knight to D4
um it's not like you win instantly
thanks to some wonderful Pawn push one
way or another it's just that you
getting strangled yeah you have no good
system on the other hand he would like
to play 94 and F5 but once you do that
my knight on H7 kind of gets alive and
jumps to G5 correct yeah so the thing is
is
I shouldn't be anxious to make any
further progress what I would do if I
was white I would be interested in
playing Knight D4 Rook H3 and
surprisingly enough playing a move like
A3 to switch the theater battle over to
the queen side because I feel I've I've
accomplished everything I need to on the
king side
but uh I want to take a pause here and
say Christian you're with guest Gregory
two in a row one of them against the
defending champion this Victory must
feel quite sweet especially with the
black pieces
yeah yeah feels feels great didn't
expect it uh to happen and uh especially
so quickly so it's especially because it
felt like out of the opening sure you
equalized but it didn't feel like you're
going to get much more than that and yet
the game at some point ended in a couple
of moves we missed it we were like okay
what happened here it was a tour like
that exactly you see you are aided by
computers so your feeling is different
so I don't see a computer evaluation so
I felt like I had initiative but of
course I didn't know whether it's more
than for equality but it was I I was
hoping so and you could notice uh right
before I played the final combination I
started repeating moves so I was very
seriously considering just taking a
drawback repetition but then I saw this
idea which I which happened in the game
and which I did not expect to happen I
saw this variation I was sure you know
he's not going to move the knight from
D2 he had other moves
um and uh I thought it's going to be and
just before we get to that point I think
this was a crucial moment when you took
on D4 and you decided to break with D5
how did you come to this conclusion what
was your assessment tell us a bit about
this position
uh obviously I felt like my development
Advantage is very important I have three
minor pieces developed versus his only
one uh so as the concept goes when you
have development Advantage open position
up so I try to do it go for a pawn break
to trade pawns an open position up uh I
also emphasize while teaching activity
is much more important than Pawn
weaknesses I didn't care about the pawn
on E6 so I just try to open and activate
my pieces as much as possible even at
this point I did too you emphasized
keeping the grip on his right
development Bishop before is actually
prophylactic movie it's obviously not
easy move to play because Bishop is very
active on C5 but he's about to complete
his development with 94 and I absolutely
have to stop this move yeah yeah even at
the expense of a pawn very nicely
assessed I have to say Rook to E4 King
to h8 another good prophylactic move
right Queen to B3 Knight to D3 and this
was the moment probably Rook 2 G4 was
the only way for him to maintain some
sort of a balance in the position not an
easy move to make very difficult I I
didn't see this move and I'm sure where
are you going with the Rook right right
right right typical computer move looks
like just a bad move but I guess now
after you told me I see certain logic
behind this move because
the main idea is that E4 is a crucial
Square for the Knight because it
protects of two it's going to jump on G5
but wherever it goes on the file it's
going to be attacked by my pieces so I
guess that's the point of Rook G4 about
such a strange move yeah it is a very
difficult mode to make rokto makes the
most sense just because you're defending
right upon on F2 and now you uh repeat
it once this is the repetition you were
talking about and you decide to go Rook
C8 immediately the blunder came right
right right so so all install Night
Moves uh
E4 this is the most natural I guess but
now you have some taken Knight D4 is
that it
um
yes yes taken 94 right right uh maybe
even I was thinking about Knight D4
right away uh but uh maybe it doesn't
matter
yeah yeah 94 also works right it's just
right easier to calculate right right
but the move I was calculating the move
I was expecting was Queen D1 again not
easy move to make very passive looking
move but I was expecting this move when
I was calculating variation Knight D4
Knight shakes D4 Knight shakes F2 Rook
chicks F2 Queen shakes D4 and now either
Queen E1 Queen F1 uh Rook C2 here so I I
wasn't sure what's going on but but it
seems is good
I was hoping yeah that that something
will good will happen there yeah Knight
F3 actually you can continue sacrificing
and then pin pin it to win it that's
what they say right right that's the
variation I was hoping for yeah no uh
great game it finished in an
anticlimactic way but still great result
for you great start the tournament
Gregory congratulations thank you yes
sir and questions
to Gregory a very nice start
and uh just uh looking at the other game
one game Maxine and oh we're gonna do
the standings first with these two
results because we just had another
result as well Vladimir has one yeah we
have two resulted games shabal of lost
against kaidanov and akopian won against
root it's exactly as Gregory
takes the lead
cooking bouncing back from his first
round loss it's a visual and it just
caught my eye and I I thought it was
quite a funny one it was the game
between Max and Patrick Wolfe a very
balanced position as you can see on the
board double pawns F6 and F5 but so
White's majority you can imagine that
white wants to play moves like rookie
one eventually contest for the e-file
you know put your Pawn on C3 I don't
know even at the cost of doubling your
pawns play Queen of three instead he
played a very uh kind of a natural
looking move Rook C1 here and it's like
this visual you've got this Pawn on D4
defended
[Laughter]
yeah you you lost the C4 pawn and D4
Pawn on consecutive moves and it's a
very easy move to miss queen takes D4
and you you don't want to trade Queens
taking the queen will cost you Rook
takes E2
so uh in fact Max ended up if you will
kind of blundering upon and excuse me uh
Patrick is actually enjoying uh the
position I would say at the moment as
last but Queen D5
looks to me like he wants to play Queen
F3 potentially
uh sacrificing a rook and also you
always have those F4 yeah so if you have
ideas let's say The Rook captures on CC
yes yes Queen goes to F3 and we would
love to play Rook C3 back right but we
cannot because the bishop is guarding
that exactly and yeah Rook takes E3 and
it could be a trick yeah it's just it
feels like that Queen is like a sconced
in that uh beautiful F3 Square again uh
Rook takes E3 those types of uh exchange
Checkers I love them I think that the
exposed white king at the cost of your
structure is really really tough and for
Patrick uh for for Patrick this would be
a big bounce back uh with the black
pieces again he starts with two blacks
just as Carissa did let's turn to the
junior section and uh
uh Andrew honk against Jason Leanne jump
into whoa what's happening where are all
the black pawns
something crazy happened this was the
game that uh the Christian has been
keeping his eye on there was that Queen
here actually a G4 right would be a
mistake and let's see how the position
blowed up
Queen
take on F3 take take everything's
hanging I was wondering how a white uh
pardon me how a black Pond ended up on
the G2 squared now we know
takes take you know this Knight takes E6
nights around King whose King is the
most vulnerable Queen B6 give me a check
or a check here
and we've caught up
with players Kate just your knee-jerk
response like what the heck yeah so you
know my coach always told me that this
Pawn like the black Pawn on G2 that's
kind of a double agent because it looks
like it's playing for black right but
it's maybe helping white to stop
everything what's happening on the king
side so maybe now is the white who is
actually happy for the pawn being on G2
and being kind of its own ancient but
what do I can do can I go and attack the
King Double Agent I like that yeah
definitely a spy you know but a double
spot yeah sometimes the white king can
take shelter behind the pond and
obviously if that G2 Pawn was missing
it'd be Lights Out game over the world
this is really not easy guys what if I
go before as black Bishop E4
should be four I was even wondering
about Bishop three but Bishop E4 has the
benefit of leaving the E6 Knight hanging
uh give me one more move let me get
something on the H file well exactly and
I I feel like I'm missing a piece The
Rook on A1
isn't
um
participating and queen B3 doesn't work
yeah queen bee yeah that's just Bishop
D5
Queen B3 Bishop Bishop five that's
that's sad that's unfortunate yeah that
is really sad
um no things are actually very forced um
obviously we have the help of the engine
but from a practical perspective this is
going to go down the wire because take a
look at the time as well Andrew only
nine minutes on the clock with such a
wild position so can I play Bishop F4
shade
yeah and Bishop H2 it's not helping
right you're gonna grab that Bishop so
I'm gonna take that with three hands
with three hands
oh boy I I was actually even looking as
as looking at some desperate shots like
Bishop G5 the idea was that I wanted to
you know slowly yeah yeah slow you down
but uh I'm thinking Bishop E4 is just
winning it's not it's Knight F4 white is
winning white is winning yeah what is
wow decisively winning but decisively
you have to be very very precise which
is not easy all right the answer let's
be very precise let's be very precise
I want you to be very prized you lead I
follow let's go very precise I'm with
you Kate what are we going to do
F4
gosh but how could that be the way
forward that doesn't stop me right yeah
I still go Rook h8 I think no we we have
to we have to be very young let's have a
check yes right that's just like that
yeah and we we put your King quote in
danger right correct and now we have to
fight as well Queen C6 check okay keep
going yeah there's no real options now
here can you have seven if you go King
F7 no I'll go four weeks
um if you go forward I go F4 ah
now
I like it very nice very nice MP3 you
walk the plank and you paid the price
very nice yeah good job you're very good
so that means you have to go back that's
kind of unfortunate for black now I can
take with the queen but maybe can I play
for the initiative now that the now that
you're not going to Checkmate me on H1
anymore
maybe I can I can keep the Queens on the
board but I can still try right still
Rook h8 yeah okay yeah maybe I should
trade maybe I should be afraid here I'm
I'm thinking yate maybe here I got here
now let's go rookie eight yeah that's
much more testing I agree
that's sneaky I want to keep the Queens
on the board I I really don't like the
end game exactly I I if you get to the
end game I feel like you probably have
it in the back but so if
if that's going to be the case
should I so okay
Rook H A I don't know am I super afraid
of this this guy is hanging it is a
Checkmate in two moves so I apologize I
was thinking Bishop I thought you were
going to come down but you have Queen
agent yeah I have Checkmate yes you do
yes I like your variation first yes sir
to capture with the queen check on C4
okay
take with the queen
check on C4 and we're here I'm assuming
the King has to go G7 G6 I'm not sure
where this is pick a pick one for now
yeah and now we can go
rookie eight I have to distract you
right because at a certain moment I have
to be cognizant that you're going to
kill me
great survival instincts yes
well thank you very much okay so we take
you take and I I'm prepping the queen H3
right yeah but I'm through I'm prepping
some kind of a defense right I've got
check and queen takes but Queen H3
Bishop H2 right pardon me Queen H3 what
for some reason I thought that this was
a check no I think what you want is
Bishop H2 and now after Bishop B5 maybe
you have the check right
yes sorry this is probably what you were
calculating something of this nature yes
but then again I have ideas so you give
me a check yep let's say I go where can
I move the King right let's go to H
five
no H5 you pick micro cup
um H7 H7
okay the thing is if you take on G do I
go rooji and I'm happy
uh
uh are you
I mean none of these Jedi Mind Tricks
I'm not sure okay maybe you are just a
second because you've got this weird
thing right yes yes you've got this
weird thing where my king could end up
walking the plank maybe I'm happy I
don't know but yeah so we can do
intermediate check there before we
before we grab the pawn on G2
yeah we give a check on e4 oh those
those intern mesos uh Tom our producer
just loves the switch and zooks and the
but that doesn't change much right I
still go King H6
I still got Rook G8 after Queen takes
you through now I've got Bishop F4 check
guess what no more divisions
punish me
uh crazy game but uh let's let's go
around a little bit because we had that
game between
um Mishra and he did play for that F5 F5
good but he played one move later right
he played Queen D7 he included Queen D7
oh that game completely changed tables
have turned in this one
Christian you have your F5 if you're not
happy
no no black is doing great right okay
yes yes F5 was was a great move well
timed and and black is doing great well
the question is why did white play the
move Bishop C3 why didn't he trade Rooks
first okay
Rook takes sure Bishop F3 now
I'm threatening made now on your F5 move
I will do the
um can I put my uh
thank you I mean for you know uh you
know that the mind uh a lot why I just
remember during the chess camps the kids
were saying don't do crossan on me
you were like what no croissant no
croissant but the problem with can I put
my Rook on E5 after Bishop C3 yes but H4
is hanging
certainly take that yes you joyfully
my question is do I have enough or any
sort of compensation uh that's what
rookie for the but the problem I'm
seeing though before we look at these
variations the problem I'm seeing
Christian is that the move Bishop C3 F5
now I can't play amperson no but you can
think you can still take the pawn on H4
right
oh okay so first of all I have to trade
no I don't think so what you can take
right on H4 immediately G6 sneaky oh I
think this is what he's calculating oh
he's trying to figure out if this is
made or not wow
which I'm not sure it is like rookie
eight
King maybe still escapes
not sure about that one oh no we have we
don't have you haven't Perpetual which
is nice it's oh you know I always felt
confident once I saw that I have at
least a draw then you know we put that
that was what uh Grand Master pal benko
would tell us
first secure the draw then play for the
win
and it's sort of like okay but pal I
have a Perpetual very good now is
there's a win but well can we play
something like Bishop A5 now oh ah not
allowing you to escape wow wow
okay just a second I want the Arbiters
to come in and do it a check
Fair commentary check
nice
the Checkmate that it's actually really
clever
um do I have to make room for my king so
you know just something of this nature
but but then I'm gonna promote the queen
right I give check back and then G7
actually I saw the queen on h8 okay I I
like it I like it better as well check
on
wow so Mishra still in trouble after
Queen takes H4 is that uh and by the way
the clock times
yeah and 10 minutes
wow well this would be quite the the
Snapback for Josiah
and whoa I thought somehow I thought
that Mishra was doing well he's doing
amazing he is yes so what are you going
to play after Queen takes H4 I can go
Queen F7 I don't have to take the Rook
actually oh
so being greedy is not good that's the
ice cold computer the assessment
but okay Queen F7 let's say I move my
Rook so I'm gonna play G6 no maybe
Knight E4 is coming okay 94 maybe you go
G6 still maybe you can go Queen G6 right
you just stop away from going there if
you go there yes that's a good point for
for me this Pawn on A3 is this snake at
my throat I really want to get rid of it
whether I do it with Bishop B4 or
whether I do it with you know
get that pawn off the board okay before
here yeah
it's getting double edged I don't know
let's go F4 four run F4 okay at least
I'm not getting mated hey keep going
take that pawn on G5
and just uh I don't know this one is not
looking good I mean you this is
aggressive
true true true true
um I know you like pawns yes sir no but
no this Pawn on F2 is really uh well it
is by far the most
uh dangerous Queen G2 maybe followed by
Knight G3
yeah I don't know G2 followed by Nike it
looks dangerous a perfidious varmint is
what I would call that pawn on F2 I mean
crazy position and we're gonna see
whether uh Josiah decides to capture on
H4 but what if we go to another game
that is kind of interesting Justin Wang
against Balaji dagupate I don't think we
spend much time here and look at those
knives C5 G4 very beautiful well this
like one of those uh Bobby Fischer Kings
Indian attack games just a second how
did we get here a peace sacrifice yeah
peace sacrifice here it comes
here not quite so fast there it is it
took a while
finally picked up the courage and took a
and what do we have
uh
uh he sacrificed a piece
but I like this move Knight d88 very
holding on to that pawn on 96. if you
want to grab that Rook feel free to do
that because two pieces for a rook right
yeah and by the way I'm also uh
intimating that this bishop on G7 okay
so he did just capture The Rook Justin
very hard for me to tell the Times by
looking at the board yeah so it's 12
minutes for Justin and 15 minutes for
Balaji I mean at First Look it looked
like white is attacking right right
maybe it's the black pieces were
actually line up on the on the f file
with the bishop there exactly it would
be seven well I'm really concerned about
your capturing twice on C3 I I'm not
proud but let me just shut down the
bishop for the moment I have two pawns
by the way and I think that's very
important two pawns for uh the rook and
two minor pieces
and there is no Queen takes H5
yeah cannot be uh captured
I am
no it it this is a judgment call I think
it's okay for white but I wouldn't be
terribly optimistic if I was white here
the minor pieces can easily uh and
you're right you're that
you know you've got the source of
counter play always in the position uh
the F2 Square in particular like if you
played a move just you know just to try
to simplify the position where you're
going after my F2 Pawn on I'm not sure
I'm not sure it's a tough one to call uh
what has captured your attention
Christian well I'm backing the junior
girls section and
um I'm looking at this game of Rose
Atwell versus karise I have to say rose
has been getting closer and closer to
maybe getting in some sort of a
technical drawing position really that
is yes
she did yes so I think we left it
somewhere around this uh place after the
move F3 we said two Bishops Pawn up show
me the conversation where's the
compensation no compensation but Bishop
takes B1 maybe not the right decision uh
Bishop to D5 followed by Bishop to E6
Bishop E7 get uh the castle going hide
the bishpony six and then make use of
your extra Pawn right makes the most
sense she decided to simplify the
position but perhaps this was not the
right way E4 okay still doing well B5 I
really like what Rose is doing despite
the fact that maybe objectively you're
losing at least you're trying to find
counter play right go C4 go B5 do
something in the position don't wait
don't wait for your opponent to kill you
just try to die on your own terms
that's the new rule wow
I can't wait to buy your books
we'll go with it
Rudy Mark twin is six so the coaching
staff in St Louis University is dying
over here
why I'm in St Louis I've got St Louis on
my mind no I know you do uh Castle and
this is what we have right now a lot of
simplifications and Carissa is shying
away from the final trade of the Queens
right because if you do that this is
going to be very close to a draw right
exactly if we exchange the B Pawn for
the C Pawn four versus three maybe in
some sort of iteration you will be able
to get a winning position but it's not
going to be easy right so
Carissa goes for Queen to C8 still a lot
of pressure by the way the engine right
now after Queen to C6 if she finds this
move it says that finally white might
have equalized balanced because you
cannot I mean you can take but if it's
not you're actually starting to be in
trouble because if you try to go for the
pawn you're not in time no you cannot
take it because you just made it and if
you try to approach it with the King you
need one more Square to get close not in
time broke the eight game over right
so this is problematic Queen to C8 15
minutes for Rose Carissa with 11 minutes
definitely not the type of game that she
wanted that she envisioned 10 moves ago
when she was completely winning with the
pawn up and the two Bishops right now
the uh trend is definitely favoring
white is favoring Rose wow especially
because Carissa came out of that opening
with that extra Pawn we really thought
she was cruising like to turn our
attention to the game of Brandon and
Kirk for a moment because Brandon
Jacobson comes into the competition as a
favorite he won his first game and you
know this was those two Bishops remember
back back in the day back here we were
saying okay uh White I'm very happy
about it very happy the Central Pawn Duo
check this out we've all seen these
types of combinations in our how to
Checkmate books we want to go D5 and
Bishop takes F6 we said okay but there
is this counter Spiel based on this
skier and then sure we get out of it and
the players have reached this position
and again white has done everything
that objectively he could he's got the
central bondos the two Bishops
traditionally speaking he's got to have
the advantage but show me just you know
like you okay go ahead and and win the
game it's still not so easy Brandon
waited pause with H3
and
white wasn't able to show too much and
in this it was this last move that
really caught my eye wow 95. right and
it's just sort of like uh okay wait a
second what's going on and we're up to
date now with the players Queen takes E3
and this moves Bishop B3 and Kirk
wait a minute you know he's really
fighting very very well against the two
Bishops uh you can't take the Knight I
don't think that this is
Kirk is better guys
forget about it right now is in the
driver's seat he's not fighting he's
trying to win this one uh
but wait a minute why why can't I take
the night keep going yeah yeah oh keep
going I'm on the right track I think
Bishop B3 how do you defend the bishop
there is a rookie one sneaky attack on
the bishop I'm just trapping it yes
forget double attack you can move your
king but yeah
okay but that's a really long
combination wow
yeah it's that Bishop on D1 the pawn on
e4 uh nice Bishop B3 that's the cold
shower because after Bishop B3 the
Knight is coming to C4 everything is in
harmony for a Black's position
he's an international Master but he
actually has two uh GM Norms already so
he's a really strong player wow
um and jumping back to the game of
Mishra because they repeating no they're
not they're not I don't know they're not
they're following your line uh okay
Bishop A5 yes I hope it's good
it is no it's not that you're hoping
that that the movie these guys are good
to be able to find the move that you
found Bishop A5 very very nice okay so
this is kind of ridiculous kind of
ridiculous the only move right now yeah
for black is B6
I actually thought about that it makes
sense you know why because the bishop on
A5 is also guarding E1 Square because if
black wants to go for some counter
attack with rookie one checkmates the
bishop is guarding it right that's a
good good direction observation that's a
good direction so the idea is you
distract the Bishop from A5 now we take
uh now you go 96.
is the only way otherwise you get
checkmated Knight E6 all right because I
cannot go rookie one right and you don't
have Bishop B4 right now so you take on
E6 you take with the queen there's no
more Bishop to B4 so if our Bishop had
been sitting there nicely on A5 and you
have Bishop we would have Bishop B4 we'd
protect the E1 Square we'd be uh that's
crappy too advanced for me don't ask me
too many details forget about the deals
right uh but B6 is the only move but
everything else is completely losing
losing if you don't play B6 you're dead
I mean finding B6 and Knight E6 right
after it
well I I can easily find the move B6
Knight E6 is not come easily he's he's
down to six minutes right now so maybe
we can
follow this I mean the idea for me would
be that you know I have to make room for
the king so I'm looking at your moves
rookie one I'm looking at you know
that's losing right immediately just
take take
the check check
go and you know what the problem is when
you don't calculate this move Bishop to
A5 from afar it's just such a hidden
move right and then you get to this
point and you start panicking because
you only have five well you know but you
know you have a prepared as white as
white yes that makes it easy then you
start to look at CL you look at the
chest clock you say hey wait a minute my
opponent's in time trouble what can I do
to make his life
and the thing is this is why this
position favors white from a practical
perspective so much is that even after
B6 you still have the perfect it's in
the pocket it's in the pocket yeah all
the time so the Perpetual check that
we're saying is here
the question Christian if we move back
before Bishop a five yeah do we want to
First give check on h8 then on H4 and
keep the queen on H4 and then playing
Bishop A5 so we give a check okay so the
question you're asking is is the queen
better on H4 than on H7 exactly and now
if we go Bishop A5 I mean I like the
queen on H7 but now I'm guarding the E7
Square you're taking away any potential
option of the king running was it better
to have the queen on H4 or H7 Christian
uh according both of them are the same
both of them are still zero zeros
because and thanks too it's only Basics
everything else is
very logical two moves B6 tonight easy
B6 I'm with you 96 that's really not in
my Consciousness I mean but really that
you only play B6 if you see 96 because
otherwise you're just giving up a pawn
for no reason well no I I can on the
contrary I can easily imagine that the
bishop on on B6 is much worse placed
than he's not going for it
that's remarkable that you find 96 and
not
wow okay sorry that is just
96 is not you know it's just not on the
radar and now the whole winning at this
point but the whole problem
for
um Mishra is that by not including the
move B6 we've allowed Bishop to uh B4
and now this was absolutely brutal from
yeah like so difficult to see and now
the thread is not that we're going to
take on D6 with the bishop because that
gets us checkmated we're going to take
on D6 with the rook and make a discover
check and by the way even this is not
easy for white either right why
but Josiah has 20 minutes right that's a
lot of time to think in such a position
and I think I'm looking for right you do
but I can take on A3 and now I know
rookie one
okay okay but no now I can take on D6
and then give you a check on h8 and take
only one
nasty but there are so many moves I mean
yes this works but the answer if we
don't take on A3 and just capture on D6
with the Rook
Ah that's nice also I mean this is still
winning it is yeah yes of course it is
because I was thinking that I take your
Bishop but yes of course take everything
there nothing to discuss
captured is extrude the pipette he said
nope I'm not gonna I'm not gonna take
the Perpetual check and let me just
refresh my board as this is the current
position he could have against his much
higher rated opponent taking the draw
but no these Juniors man
they swing for the I don't want no stink
and draw okay 76. this is a major
tournament they want to show their best
and again you have 20 minutes against
four minutes also you are playing the
Young youngest GM ever I mean there's
the time to show off right exactly and
you've got to play Queen takes E6
there's no other choice here for uh
Mishra this queen if you take with the
Rook I've got Queen AJ check pick up the
pawn on G7 but I also have Bishop D4 and
again that Rook holding that the bishop
holding the E1 Square we could have
played B6 and you know sideline the
bishop
I mean this is a great game I seem
Mishra wanting to make a move because
there's only less than four minutes left
but I have another cool game do you want
to stay here well please there's still
plenty to go in this one yeah
which which is we'll get back to this
veterans to the seniors Championship we
have Maxine Logie against Patrick Wills
really nice uh positional sacrifice just
to stay in the Juniors for a second
because Andrew I think is putting the
finishing touches maybe we can update
that before we go to the seniors okay
just a second Andrew Hong
oops I got the wrong guy I keep going
from the turn Andrew did you say Andrew
Hungary versus Jason oh this was that
crazy first of all we thought that white
was busted after the move Bishop E4
which was played but Queen C7 check was
also played Queen C4 check King went
back to D7 and now a really nice move by
Andrew Bishop bringing the next Rook to
the game I was dreaming of this uh but I
couldn't get it to work for me when we
were analyzing uh we were looking at
Queen C6 right instead of Queen C4
I think we were yes and then the King
was escaping to F7 yes and then yep and
then we were Rook takes E4 and
everything so he went before physical
move you don't allow the king to escape
27 Bishop before very nice touch
and now it's all about that King it's
kind of trapped on the open freeway
there you know there's a e-file D file
and C file are all open and sometimes we
just go back to the basics right let's
finish the development The Rook in the
corner is doing nothing so let's bring
it to the game and that's gonna be a
Checkmate soon absolutely that looks
like uh Andrew as you say finishing
touches but you were saying the seniors
yes let's go there
against Patrick Wolfe did we see an
exchange sacrifice after all we did not
see it but it did did happen let's just
see what happened you go a little bit
back you were predicting it's going to
happen we saw after Queen D5 Rooks
Patrick said I'm waiting I I've got to
seize Carpe Diem seize the moment
and queen F2 E5 whoa
I'm confused by the play
but now Bishop D6 and just G3 no I go
Queen C3
you're gonna trade my queen yes I am
right so I have to be careful otherwise
That'll be amazing right yeah no if it
was Bishop D sorry Bishop C5 was played
but if Bishop D6 yes it would be amazing
like that I resign except except maybe
you have to resign after trading the
Queens which is why he played Bishop C5
by the way we have this position and
give me your give me your best judgment
whatever I mean that's why I'm a little
worried about F4 being played exactly
which means you should probably stop it
uh be thinking about Queen C4 in order
to but wait a minute
ah Queen B2
there is Bishop tanks
how cute is that that is very what what
no I can trade Queens huh
you can play a fork
well I I don't care as white I just want
to trade Queens even at the cost of the
E3 pawn and yeah you have to decide
whether this end game favors
whoever but I want to get those Queens
off the board as white I mean and I'm
willing to play I'm willing to give up
the E3 Pawn to do that so I'm thinking
Queen B2 and Max is back in the game
he's fighting at least yeah I was
thinking black is having Advantage but
maybe if we trade Queens what is fine by
the way just to clarify how how big an
advantage would you
you know uh but no I I did not achieve
that after the move Bishop C5 uh what's
caught your eye in this crazy round two
uh taking place Christian no I was uh
looking at the seniors I was following
your lead guys yeah and um I was
checking on Igor Escape Malik my pick to
win the tournament right he's not doing
well he's not doing it no he's he's
still completely lost it seems like he
never got out of it maybe got some
slight chances to minimize the advantage
for a white uh but it just simply wasn't
meant to be and right now after Rook C7
the simple either Knight to D4 which is
to my eyes at least the most uh easy
move to make in the position either
Knight to H4 both with the same idea to
attack the pawn on F5 they just seem
decisive
um I am upon up already
I'm primed to get another one on F5 and
your king despite the fact that we're in
the end game is still not safe on G7
because once uh Knight lands on F5
you're in trouble so the question is how
do you continue after Rook to E5
and if he finds the simple answer G3
followed by F4 right and understands
that there is absolutely no checks that
you have to worry about as um as white
right yeah then he's in trouble uh black
that is so Knight to D4 and by the way I
think it was played yeah I think as we
were discussing this was played I'm
expecting Rook to E5 I don't see any
other ways in which you can actively
defend the F5 Pawn Yeah you have to
defend the F5 Pawn if you lose that one
I mean it's yeah it's just bad over the
the thing is your king gets super
exposed in a position a topsy-turvy game
that I still haven't got in my eye grips
on is the game between Joel Benjamin and
Dimitri gurvich when we left it I really
like the grip the grip that Joel was
establishing on the position but the
grip was loose after the move F6 I
really thought that Joe was just going
to play Bishop to D3 capture the Knight
you know put his Knight on D4 and say
I've got the better minor piece he
didn't do that he invited the Knight
back into the game and once uh the night
was back into the game Dimitri said I've
got to take I've got to take advantage
of the moment I'm gonna play the move E5
takes takes Knight takes and now it
feels like a three result game Bishop E2
93 and it still has that feeling of like
a three result game I don't know really
what's going on help me out Kate what's
your take yeah so can you just move back
a little bit why didn't we take the
phone on E5 what was happening there why
didn't yes black could just take the
pawn on E5 I'm assuming we do the same
we recapture as well
there are no like the thing too seems
weak doesn't it
it's not so easy to jump to the C2 I've
got Knight D4 as a defense
okay yeah and it's not easy to defend
the night okay got it so 93 have to do
that Rook D2
and now Bishop is five I do want to
attack exactly uh for for for me it's
it's interesting that Joe you know
didn't reach for the night but he played
Bishop to D3
it was a trade now we take with the pawn
and we the structures changed and by the
way we have a move on the board and the
move was Rook on A8 to C8 just saying
I want to Checkmate you and please A4
yeah please just don't do anything
yeah let me play A4 and life will be
good now I think it's incumbent to play
you know you've got to defend this
threat right and kind of renew your
ideas of Knight takes A5 uh it feels
like a three result game it feels like
black is pushing a little bit right but
I do have to be careful about the
opponent E5 for white
so it's there so I like maybe A4 yeah
Knight D4 okay you got me
and this is where you're saying you've
got to be careful that this Pawn
um
yeah the the for the moment it feels
like black has an initiative but how
does he follow up he's got a he needs
something very very concrete right here
pushing the Knight to D4 is only helping
white I don't know because you could you
could still continue the the whole the
whole line right it has a very kind of
forcing nature to it uh with A3 uh crazy
stuff going on you're still on the
novikov game just because there is a
very funny and very uh interesting
pattern that I don't see very often uh
at this position uh King to G6 was the
move played The Rook to C3 okay just
played yeah but he had this golden
opportunity to play the move B6
Bishop B5
you cannot take on C1 because I take
only eight first with a check right and
then I pick up the reconcil one so you
have to defend the Rook the rook and now
I go Bishop E8
oh wow that's very nice right wow you
cannot take with the Knight because
you're paying right if you take with the
Rook that's yeah just simply giving me
King G7 King H6 don't work because
you're losing them F5 and the Knight
gets involved in play as well and uh
King to um H7 I guess you can just
simply take and then F6 is hanging yeah
so very nice sequence that would have
ended the game uh he didn't find it to
C3 is also very good by the way and to
be honest the Practical choice in the
position uh Rook 2 C3 was played H4 once
again
he can do that he can do Basics and by
the way if he doesn't do it his
Advantage is starting to slip a little
bit you can try to go Knight F3 he
played G3
okay this is not great
this is not great because right now
maybe I can go Rook C8
okay things are getting a bit uh a bit
muddy in in the position because the
knights hanging the night yes sure oh
but Bishop
yeah so Malik may be recovering after
this I have to say I mean with only
three minutes on the clock for Igor
navikov and this crazy position after
Rook to C8 you missed your chance to go
B6 and finish the game he played 19 H3
wow that once again B6 and Bishop B5
it's all about that B6 movie that's
hilarious wow but you know what speaking
of little town we have karisa it's very
low on time what is happening in that
position we had Queen and game
with coins running I thought it was a
major piece endings with Rooks when we
left it it was right here yes it was
this move Queen and we were thinking
Queen C6 and that Rose had fought her
way back into equality she played B6
E3
Queen season this is crazy what's going
on in this game yeah we're at Queen and
Rook end game and like we have black has
two pawns running and Karissa has only
one minute 29 seconds to go and still
needs to make nine moves
trying to get present at this position
myself I don't quite have it I think
black is for Choice okay I mean but the
the clock times
tell me that Carissa is uncertain as
well that uh
she's just played Queen takes C4 by the
way restoring material equality uh
and instantly Queen B2 instantly but
nowadays after 22 I think it's just an
easy draw uh guys let's go to Andrew
Hong because Andrew is just about to
finish his game okay wow what's
happening there Andrew Hong against
Jason Liang yeah that was the king stuck
on the open files uh game uh we left it
here we just saw the move Bishop F4
Queen H3 okay threat of mate and one but
it's my turn
giving a check check again
and we're about to see a handshake let's
see the handshake yeah that's not me
Checkmate is uh about to appear on the
board
we have to go to that game of uh Andrew
Han and Jason there it is
is there a bishop on D6 there is a
bishop there is a bishop yeah from that
yeah there's a handshake yep
nice game by Andrew Hong and a great
start for this young man I mean he's two
out of two he's leading the tournament
and he's showing exceptional form right
now and let's just go to the game of uh
Josiah and Mishra because that was that
crazy game and by the way after 96 it
takes on E6 Queen takes E6 Mishra did
he's down on time Bishop B4 Rook to d8
Jack Jack
and let me take that pawn on him again
I'm not interested and the problem is
the desirable Rook Ewan walks into queen
of seven check that's nasty that's
really nasty he's picking up the Fawn on
A3 with perfect timing uh check on the
board and what's the clock times again
yeah so we see uh Josiah Stephen having
30 minutes but abhimanyu and Mishra
having only one minute one by the way
this is last month this is move 39. this
is movement last move before the time
control
and it feels like this should just be a
wave of
if I check and play G7
well I think the easiest well and
probably the best practical ways to just
check on h8 check and take on D6 right
check on the h8 and I'm assuming the
King has to go to D7 and now take on D6
now take on D6 wait what this is the
easiest way this is Queen G7
Queen G7 oh okay just go into this empty
I mean you go King C8 I take on D6 and
right I have a queen and a lot of Pawns
a lot of Pawns I'm not going to promote
my g-pawn but I do have a lot of parts
it's agreed agreed that just feels like
the easy technical way of winning the
position I guess right
and check it's for some reason I was
really
wanting to play the move G7 and trying
to retain everything you know keep the
phone on G7 keep my queen on h8 does
look like uh Josiah is cruising what
other games are happening
let's look at Igor novikov again what
happened there then we keep coming back
to this game because it's like crazy
things are happening it took on let me
bring up this so we had the G3 Knight
take H3 and we've been we've been
pounding the table for B6 Bishop here
Bishop E8 takes on H4 takes on F2
H5 check he blew it
he blew his Advantage but he did who
what he did well because now why King
can go to G5 G5 yes yeah now the knights
are gonna be really strong wait a minute
wait a minute what happens after Knight
F3 and Rook takes it but here I have an
id1 at the end yes sir so I can give you
my knight no problem
Knight F3 check King Chief taking over
King F4 or King F4 I'm thinking I'm
taking this Knight but I'm forgetting
now you might actually be worse yeah no
that's with check you have to be careful
I beg you pardon no I I beg your pardon
I that
and Igor has less than two minutes for
how many moves seven moves seven moves
seven more moves so he has to play Fast
he does
and this is a complicated position we
can give check here check there okay so
what happens if I check on E6
you have oh you take on E6 right because
the C7 is hanging yeah so you have to
taste and then then I give you Fork then
you give me the bishop right that's
right and the crazy part is if you
recapture with Bishop I'm gonna take
your rook and give you another four oh
that's right it's the knights man nicer
It's Tricky nights
and this is not looking good guys I I
have a feeling this might actually turn
completely the other way around
remarkable
I mean Malik is your pick right
Christian I I'm I'm good I'm happy for
my pick but at the same time from a plus
five advantage to plus maybe losing
there's a crazy thing about Chess
sometimes like seeing this move be six
Bishop B5 game over right we are winning
on the spot and then you make one
inaccuracy second in accuracy and then
that is my experience in my chess games
you know I slowly slowly lose any
advantage I have and the clocks are
becoming a factor I mean he's down to
his last 30 seconds wow and he's only on
move 34. so we're gonna be playing only
on increment this is panic time yeah
Igor Navigator because because all of
these Forks including this Knight D1
check for
yeah I mean okay is it time to play what
how do I press the panic I mean it's
time to play you know it's like 13
seconds make a move don't flag ten
seconds Igor don't flag don't fly just
make a move he might have forgotten
about the time no 96. oh but that's the
blunder that we just looked at that
loses Rook takes E6 it's over Rook takes
c66 wins
for Melissa and he's he's reaching for
that night he saw he saw the the forks
wow Rook takes E6 what a turnaround big
big survival skills right from Malik
Rook takes he fought well he he really
did yes that that is true that is true
he really did fight but we have to you
know Igor found all the great moves we
he really built up that Advantage he did
but he's he's blown it uh in time
trouble as
Maurice Ashley says time travel makes
fools of all of us and Knight D1 check
and the tables have turned completely
around yes
it takes C3
King takes C3 and suddenly
I mean wow
wow they're still you know there's still
hopes to make a draw in this position
don't get me wrong right it's not
completely over but we know who's
playing for a win in this one absolutely
what what a turnaround and uh yeah what
if we go back to Juniors and the game
Justin Wang against Balaji dagupati we
have um Rook against two pieces but the
Rook has some Pawns was this the Fisher
attack yes this is okay let's just go
quickly he he
took
and
there goes the Rook
these are some crazy games they're going
on here King S7 and what do we have we
have one Pawn One Pawn One Pond for the
exchange but uh
it's good news that this bishop isn't
you know like if you put that pawn on F5
I think the piece is just overwhelm The
Rook the fact that this bishop is
actually a passive piece uh is an
indication to me that maybe maybe black
uh isn't just like winning but I do
think black is for Choice Carissa by the
way is repeating she's getting off to a
slow start as she's looking very slow
start to the um
to the Arbiter to her standards I mean
this is not a good sign but at the same
time we've seen Carissa come back from
much worse and we I mean we also have to
give her credit because she started with
two blacks yeah so you know she can be
fighting back with why just keeping her
cool with black and then showing teeth
with white but she's not very happy
about the draw you can see her attitude
just like shoot another draw well the
thing is she knows that this is her last
chance to win the championship
yeah she stopped the clock and she's
going to call the Arbiter over and she's
going to say this your Arbiter this is
what I'm playing playing for I'm going
to play this move
has to write down the move she's playing
that's the proper way to clean draw
you're right and I don't think she wrote
it down so the Arbiter is asking her
what she wants to do that's the move
playing the move exactly
what is that your move yeah that's what
you want to do let's let me check uh
with the uh with the computer
as well but okay this is a dead draw
position three against three in any case
uh Christian what do you have for us I
have um an interview for you sorry I
thought I thought you had this great
position and you were gonna show us uh
how it went yet we do have Andrew with
us Andrew congratulations throughout the
through a great start for uh youth the
last bit about the opening phase and I
want to emphasize this position because
it was quite crazy it felt at least
visually that you're completely breaking
through right but it's not that easy
after this H4 Rook G8 what are you
thinking about taking it like this
yeah actually so
um when he played this G5 F6 idea I mean
I saw it was a legal move but I I
thought there's no way this could work
but then the more I looked at it it was
a complete mess it was so hard to judge
and um I actually missed that after H4
Rook G8 um Rook Gates a really strong
move yes this move I missed because and
it's not clear what to do if I play
Queen h6k F7
um the threat is Rook HJ here so even my
take on G5 Rook h8 should be good for
black yeah exactly really bad
yeah so yeah King F7 I should play Queen
H5 check
um yeah it's a question of assessment
right yeah
I couldn't see clearly what to do for
why
um this huge mess there's so much going
on but I decided to choose Queen D3 and
I think that was the right decision and
you were trying to open up the position
trying to get to his King he was trying
to get your king complete mess yeah it
was a complete mess um I think after the
critical moment was after CD 265 you're
supposed to take edn position is
extremely complex I I didn't see it and
because Queen A8 looks scary but after
King G7 Knight H5 King h8 there's
nothing here so
um after edl's just planning on playing
nice too and we have very very
complicated position um
all of the results possible but after GF
almost impossible to assess it yeah
actually Bishop D7 yeah such a random
placement for all the pieces more or
less right but after GF DC I'm not sure
what he missed because this looks not
great for black takes and then there's
this move Queen B6 was very key
um perhaps this is what he missed this
might have been what he missed because
his King is um getting cooked in the
open and yeah the idea is Queen t7
Knight F4 yeah and I actually think he
had the best defense was Bishop E4 here
I think yes
um he did play 57 takes Quincy for this
key he's supposed to play King E5 here
that's right and here I was calculating
a lot it's actually a lot harder than
thinking about F4 I can't click here
Bishop D2 Bishop D2 some dual threats of
f4 bishop and then Bishop B4 also have
rookie for rookie one which wins and I
the move I calculate for black hero is
Rook G4 okay looks like it might hold on
but then it wasn't that clear to me I
didn't have much time but I thought here
Queen C6 might win
what is this type of Chess yeah no I
didn't see Bishop H4 but oh my goodness
but but I figured I figured
I figured he actually went for King E5
there I should find a win there somehow
but um yeah King design was a nice
little trap obviously the idea is a
rookie for Queen F2 and tables are
turned Yes again but uh unfortunately I
have Bishop F4 which I think wins
clearly on the spot yeah Rook D1 and his
King is just toasted yeah yeah Andrew
congratulations uh good start for you
guys join the conversation any questions
for our current leader uh first of all
that was a really thrilling game was
there any moment there Andrew that you
felt like I may have missed something or
did you feel so confident throughout
um
after C takes D5 I was expecting Ed as I
said but after gf3
I hadn't I was a little bit afraid I was
missing something but I really couldn't
see what he wanted
um so I just had to trust my calculation
there's there's a lot to calculate but
um right it seems to all work for white
so uh you know my sort of thinking was
I'll just play you know what I think and
then we'll see what he does and then
we'll just go from there move it move by
move a thrilling Victory congratulations
thank you uh and Andrew I have one more
question I feel like Jason he played
really fast in the opening very worried
about his preparation or did you just
think F6 is really bad and you're gonna
do great there
yeah actually so he played this C5 line
which I believe he doesn't usually play
um assumed he I assume he has some
preparation here so I I chose a slightly
different line
um from what I usually play and he was
still playing quickly um but I think
generally he is already out of book but
he he maybe the type of player he just
plays fast or maybe in this certain game
he wanted to you know put pressure on
the clock but I'm pretty sure he was out
of book um just playing quickly though
and it really wasn't easy to um
and I'll find the right way for white
yeah great game congratulations
absolutely absolutely and uh we'll up uh
date uh with the results uh Kate let's
take a look yeah let's take a look at
the girls junior we have Alice Lee
Rochelle and Zoe tank all having one
point Karissa
and Atwell half a point I believe we are
missing some results right we have a
result of Carissa making a a draw and
then in the junior section we have
Andrew just went yeah Andrew just won
against Jason Liang and all the other
games are being played no the senior
section we had two results I believe
already victories by uh akopian and
kaidana yes
and in fact all of the games are kind of
reaching the time control right now
so a lot of players will just take their
time finally
so let's go let's go to the abhimanyu
Mishra steerman game what is happening
there or do we have another game we
might have a repetition coming in that
uh Mo versus a Liu game
in the junior girls section okay irishmo
Kelsey Leo by the way it does look to me
like Mishra is losing he's got that the
the two Rooks versus the queen but
there's too many pawns uh for the queen
so he did exactly what Christian
suggested right
get that position
technical way out I guess yeah
all right so let's take a look at Iris
Moe and Kelsey Leo game
there is supposed to be a repetition
we're going to see a handshake very soon
in that one yes
okay so the night before and I think
yeah they've already called The Arbiter
we have both of the Arbiters there
Chris bird had to go to the attic for
this one he's not happy about it
stop by the way we talk about the
players
and getting norms and titles and things
like that but also one of the things
that the happens here in St Louis is we
give a lot of arbiter titles as well
because the Arbiters get Norms by
hosting National as well as
international events and they get their
Arbiter titles by uh being Arbiters at a
big important national championships
like this one so we have also here in St
Louis established a lot of arbiter
titles well just a quick shout out to
the people that you never want to hear
from you don't want to hear any appeals
or anything
and let's take a look stay in the girls
championship and let's take a look at
Gracie prasanna Zoe tank is that going
to be another repetition I guess we have
yes seen a couple of repetitions a check
and rugby one Rook D4 uh reminding black
that the pawn on A5 is hanging and then
we see a check and this is where the two
players have been repeating it's always
thinking whether to move back claim a
troll
but then can we kind of draw already
that I don't know
yes I think she can write it yes so she
can write down move Rook B1 and pause
the clock and claim the draw or she can
play something different and continue
with the fight I was wondering what what
happens if I play Rook before trying to
continue the fight I'm assuming you take
on D6 right I don't think so
Pawn game pawn and game I think that can
be true what do you do
I actually no I think you're right yeah
let's go for it
wait I'm scared what do you mean
no you get okay yes you can let's let's
go for it because if Rook takes these
six let's take a group takes D6 right if
I recapture back with the king I think
before taken before
Pawn takes now I go King D3 and I stay
on C King D5 I think I stay on seat when
B2 I just think the passive way out uh
sorry you go King E3 no no what do you I
go King situ you go King C2 yeah
really right I mean okay King C4 yeah
let's go me too I just stay like this
and he just stays
okay that's kind of remarkable you don't
believe me well no I mean look I'm not
the one with the chess engine so I mean
I just yeah I I see no actually the
detective uh fast and check this one
with the engine but oh I'm sorry
you got the engine right there I assume
I I assume it's easy enough Maybe I'm
Wrong let's see so if we go G6 here
exactly I I
no it's not wrong it seems It's a draw I
think it is a draw after G6 okay yeah
King C2 I guess I cannot launch the trip
with my king to the king side because
you have King B3 oh but we have Rook B
we do have Rook B5 so she's not claiming
draw she's trying to continue and
playing I mean she won a game yesterday
so maybe she wants to uh
try for another win
we'll keep an eye on this game as we do
take a break and we'll see you on the
other side for more play of round two of
the national championships
[Music]
welcome back to Saint Louis salads it's
so good to see you here thank you it's a
pleasure to be here and I have I have
followed your games for a long while and
then we have played a couple of games as
well you have been playing some awesome
chess lately what's your secret
um I guess I've just been like studying
a lot and I think uh playing in
tournament
um I played in a lot of drone
tournaments over the past few months and
um most recently I think I played in a
New York nine tournament and a few
really strong tournaments before that
and I think these tournaments have
helped me not just like get experience
but just playing against such strong
players
um and I've had some like both a mix of
disappointing results and good results
so I think I guess it's just like
important to keep up like no matter what
your results are and to keep playing
against these John players and I think
that's definitely helped me improve the
most in the past three months you
completed your International Master Norm
congratulations on that I was very happy
to see that and do you have any plans on
getting GM title anytime soon do you
have like exact goal to get it you know
exact date for it or you're just like
going with the flow
um yeah thank you so for the GM I'm like
that would definitely take at least
another few years if not longer but I
hope that um for now I'm just sending my
goal to improve
um like slowly and I think if I like am
able to improve then the norm should
come but if I'm still like stuck they
won't come as easily so I think like
just working on improving my skill level
is the most important thing right now
um and that's I guess sort of my uh
short-term goal playing back-to-back
tournaments are pretty tiring I know
that from my own experience how are you
feeling right now
um well I feel like a bit tired I didn't
have too much time to prepare for this
tournament just like a couple days in
between yeah um but I like this format
because for this tournament it's one
game a day so you get time to prepare in
between games I know right I don't like
us or US Open a month I feel you yeah
like two games a Day Too Much I I bet it
is especially like playing back to back
two in a row I played couple of uh
events like that tournaments like this
uh two rounds a day back to back I was
completely exhausted and you're coming
out of those tournaments and then
playing another very serious event here
so yeah but I'm glad that actually there
will be a rest day here so um there's
gonna be some like time to post like
focus on chess and relax between games
um but yeah so for this tournament I'm
like pretty excited to be playing
that's awesome I'm glad to hear that is
there anything uh you would like to
achieve one thing you would like to
achieve this year
um I guess like I will be planning a lot
of drone tournaments
um like
uh I've actually recently got invited to
uh like the
women's super Swiss or it's in the Isles
of a man yes I love Mount yeah yes so I
mean I guess like I hope that I'll be
able to like have a really good
experience here especially since it's
one of my first like serious
International tournaments um but overall
I guess it's like trying not to have too
many regrets
um like not losing gameplay pandering uh
like a piece or something
um and just trying to like improve
throughout the year but I don't have any
specific oil because I feel like if I
like that a good put a bit too much
pressure although I definitely like I
guess my main goal is Improvement
that is awesome and do you have any like
time to do something else besides just I
know you have been like playing for two
years or three years back to back and
everything do you have any other Hobbies
um yeah I actually do contest math
um and that's like something that I do
like for fun that's my main other hobby
uh I think like it's actually kind of
similar to chess in the way that you
have to think of Creative Solutions to
problems that arise
um and yeah but mostly I do spend a lot
of time on chess
um over the summer I've been playing in
like a lot of back but to backwards so
there isn't too much time for other
stuff but I'm really enjoyed just like
the process that sounds great thank you
so much and good luck with the
tournament thank you
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why just as
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's Grandmaster William
tokerchonova I will be doing social
media for the U.S Juniors and seniors
chess championships follow us in our
social media and get more exciting
behind the scenes action
foreign the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr Jeannie
Karen singfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a non-profit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American cop as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome back we have some
results of this round too Kate yeah you
were saying yesterday he was a very
decisive game here we had same draws at
12 years
yeah Alice lastly one of the
pre-tournament favors along with
Chrisley yes getting Nick for some half
points and in the Juniors the result
thus far I think we have one one hunk
one against Leanne however the seniors
we've got as a whole slew of decisive
games Maxine glugy once again Patrick
Wolf Shabbat lost to kaidanov and
akopian won against root for Patrick
Wolff he crashes to his second loss
which was really annoying because he was
Frankly Speaking a little bit better he
went for a speculative exchange
sacrifice that I didn't think it was
going to turn out this badly but it sure
did and the final
position was that well we got the queen
traded off and well there's a reason why
Rooks are stronger than Bishops yeah
exactly
and let's just jump to well hold on what
game is this this uh Shreya mangalam
against Rochelle Wu yeah nice to talk to
say that's the Mishra game the queen
against the two Rooks and wow looks like
Mishra is losing
um Bishops of opposite colors the first
thing that stands out to me Rochelle is
trying desperately to save this position
so Russia is
enjoying healthy extra Pond but opposite
colored Bishops and Russia wants to go
after those spots exactly there is a
threat to do that so we're more or less
obliged I would say to start with the
move King D2 because again I'm seeing
Bishop B1 right and I want to be able to
meet Bishop B1 with A3 and I want to be
able to meet Bishop A2 with King C2 and
trap that Bishop like okay
so
you said this is the current position
but what's what's your take uh good
winning chances for white because again
these three pawns are all on dark
squares kind of is encouraging me to
yeah think about going after them myself
right I was also thinking about maybe G5
break but that's going to be help black
for exchanging some pawns so I like just
to move the king back kind of recover
and like make sure my pawns are safe and
then I like your normal Bishop A3 just
go go after those pawns well that was
why I wanted to play Bishop to uh
um
B12 to provoke the move A3 so that uh
you wouldn't have that I mean eventually
you're gonna have a bishop C3 I I would
say Sharia is
a good chance of still of of winning
this wrong game she's got the outside
pass Pawn but let's go to Christian uh
who has guest in studio thank you yes
sir Max Team an important victory for
you but not an easy one in fact it felt
like at some point you might have been
even in trouble how did you assess uh
these games I thought after I played
this horrendous move G3 I was the worse
which I've seen now this is absolutely
true I was trying to find a way to like
get an advantage but
you know but the solution is much worse
than the than the problem so at this
point you were playing for an advantage
yes thought that you're better I thought
I could be better I thought I I can't
I'm not worse so what would I do to play
for an advantage I have to stop at four
F or to play G3 but then I want to play
Queen E5 I was like oh my God but you
invited this Rook takes C3 you showed
him hey take on E3
I was worried about there should be five
here that was the moment I was really
and probably this was the much better
solution for him that's right because it
just stops Rook F4 which is my idea
about Queen of three so now I was
thinking okay if I play like Queen E2
then a number of moves uh Bishop D4
notably was what I noticed later and
that's the main one yeah but F4 is also
pretty good but yeah yeah but uh so so
no Queen E2 but he took on E3
it was very surprising because I thought
I mean I could only I'm playing for a
win now although yeah you weren't
worried about the weakness of your king
I wasn't I mean I I mean no not typical
GM level you like the material well
first of all like material and secondly
you know my King has squares and you
know the best he can hope for some
Perpetual so you know why well I'll just
be in trouble
huh yeah
yeah yeah and then I was seeing you know
ideas like
what would I play Queen C4 here no okay
maybe yeah Queen's four works as well
yeah
although they're animals but yeah now
I think the execution part was uh pretty
good very clean okay good thanks
thankfully yeah I didn't I didn't want
to play E4 because who knows but but
although you know obviously it's a good
move but like I'm like you know if I
take only four I want my queen to go
through eight so I played Rook C first
minimal difference yeah and then and
then I and then I'm like okay but this
is
I actually thought about playing A4
uh-huh before Rook C5 uh but then Bishop
D6 and six I mean it's bad but it's like
at least
so I was because that saves the temple
over the game right yeah not to play but
you know then I had to work and like
okay then you have to worry about yeah
some transitions yeah who knows who's
faster but I've been doing some studies
lately and it moves like A4 prop you
know come in quite often so yeah
and it worked out just nicely after that
screening basically Max an important
victory for you with the black pieces
last year you made it
with the white pieces excuse me well
last year you made it tie breaks you
almost won the championship what is the
platform this year and did you do some
training a lot of training before this
one I played one tournament uh
Philadelphia Open just stay open yeah
like in fact the game went first 12
moves went like in this game but then
eight moves later I won against than I
am so I was pretty much it but uh like I
have one on 20 moves and so I was kind
of happy that you know I can still
figure out an attacking idea well Joel
was saying that he actually prepared for
every single participant before the
tournament did you do anything remotely
close to that I probably shouldn't say
because that would give away some stuff
but uh
[Laughter]
no just a congratulations uh Max I did
have uh one question because I I mean it
it had the appearance to me perhaps it
wasn't did you blunder it just this
moment I I mean okay uh objectively
probably it's equal but you have a
Superior Pawn structure right you have
the potential of creating a candidate
black is thinking Bishop H6 and rookie
four right right and so you went C4 yeah
he took it and he took another one yeah
you didn't blunder D4 no no no because I
mean no no I understood that you know
once once the Deep one's gone my Bishop
was alive and I can always win one of
the pawns uh so I should be at least
equal and probably at most equal but you
know right so I mean rather than playing
in your move Rook D1 and the sequence
went C for takes on C4 because the H1 is
a is a Target and and so is you know my
queen has to leave because Bishop H6 in
there yeah so so are they a move like
for example uh Queen F3 or so you don't
like this it takes on F5
and then therefore is a threat and and
uh
and I couldn't understand why you mean I
would be okay here yeah I thought it
could be worse you I see okay yeah
Bishop F6 is also threat so right at the
very least I'm gonna trade on G5 and The
Rook comes to E2 which is not what I
want not not ideal not ideal I mean
another way to play through it so I said
okay well I gotta get out of this uh
situation here gotcha all right uh nice
nice nice well a nice turnaround and
good luck uh in your campaign thank you
yes absolutely absolutely three decisive
games in the series wow
and let's just uh jump to the Juniors
because there was this incredible game
that was going on and we didn't really
understand it between uh Brandon and
Kirk and uh eventually
we thought that Kirk was better after
this move Knight E5 that was that
shocking move right remember yes a
little bit we got to double the room yes
this position and then suddenly Kirk was
better after this star move Bishop B3
the the bishop on V1 was trapped in that
variation where we take the Rook we end
up with a trap Bishop on B1 and Brandon
was suddenly the one trying to hold on
and eventually they did draw but uh
it was through a repetition okay very
nice and that was our that's a good save
by Brandon I mean the first draw the
Juniors yeah that's true
so let's take a look at the updated
um results for round two in the Juniors
we have Jacobson who drew against
gazarian and honk who won against Liang
and the girls we have a lot of draws
today what happened look as well Drew
yet Mo Drew Leo prasanna Drew tang and
Yan Drew Lee so it's only
only mangalam against Wu still playing
it's
saying where he's got the queen versus
the two Rooks but it's about all of
these pawns that uh White has and
White's last move Queen uh dropped back
to F2 so the pawns pinned you ready just
to nicely play A4 A5 and well it looks
uh to to my eyes that Mishra
sadly yes I am losing and if you play
Rook G2 with black then I go with my
queen to D4 and then you cannot attack
me right and I'm playing this A5 on my
next move the A5 is the problem with
euroka it suddenly did occur to me that
you could continue with Rook to C7 but
can I still play A5 after sure yes you
can pretend like I'm gonna hide on V5
right I run
first of all I'm not going to take
without rocon situ no I want to take
with the other one and then go back to
C6
but now your Rooks are kind of Tangled
and I just run H4
yes and no
um because I go to Stage seven
there's a tension no
it's true I I somehow I don't want to
give you another point
I think it's just uh you you can chill
right you can play Slowly just defend
our soldiers and by the way this is a
kind of a cute
trap that you don't see that often the
the queen spearing one of the two Rooks
so by the way we do have H4 no we have
King B7
sorry excuse me I'm gonna just refresh
my my board for a moment we have after
the move Queen F2 we did not see Rook
here he went King B7
kind of prophylactically get away from
the diagram H4
so you can't put the Rook here whoops
that's a check so I'm assuming the Rook
has to come down
now I feel I want to go King B3 followed
by C3 just slowly slowly push my
soldiers as you said I I
one of those
the the those video games where you know
the aliens keep coming on the board
hey they're marching just don't start
with C3 no C4 no by the way I feel like
I see a really cool move in this game
Justin Wang against Balaji dagupati can
we just go there absolutely if it's a
total mistake or actually cool idea
there was uh King E7 Jack King here
Queen F7 E5 now F4 let's go
[Laughter]
yeah I mean make my day
okay F4 I guess he's worried about the
vulnerability of his King I'm inviting
that check but I think I'm gonna go to
H2 okay and just hide on H3 and I mean I
do want to capture
um
E5 I think and open up the king there
well let's go check King H3 let's take
the pawn because you always have to look
at captures though okay I capture and
now I have a king move right so let's
run for the hills and a hope that the
Rook is hanging right A7 check
can I keep running for the hills no now
on D4 I'm going to capture with Rook
that is killing excuse me
um and you cannot go to C4 because then
I guess I have to run for the hills no I
can't run that way because there's a
check and then you will take so once
again C5 you went here I have to go here
and now I can hear hmm
I wonder if I take on D4 with the queen
oh Queen takes on D4 oh sorry with the
queen
because now both of your pieces are
going to be attacked
so yeah
but okay this is a bit F4 was a legit
idea right uh Christian did he make sure
because he played like blunder he played
uh just at the moment that we were we
were really giving it a look over he
played Queen A7
no he didn't
what
the queen is on f8 now it's on G8
so we thought Christian so you wanted to
go F4 first with the queen on F sub yes
computer doesn't like it I assume C1
okay
is the move
Queen C1 and pick up some pawns there
okay so that variation that we were
looking at probably works for black it
does work for black yeah okay
so that's why Balaji went with wood I
think they're just repeating right
so about to sign the score sheets E5
check check
and okay just moving back and forth with
the queen queen f8 back check queen of
Faith Queen G8
don't go to F5
after Queen G8 what do you think about
that position Christian what is computer
saying is it a draw or can white be
fighting for something or just digging a
hole to grave with a four current
position is just a draw yes it's uh it's
equal so queen of Fate Queen G8 probably
is the right way to to do things
and there's not much either side can do
uh earlier in our broadcast uh the
matchup between our two Arthurs it's not
it's not
the most common name I want to say in
the Chess World Arthur that's true
the Russian version of Arthur uh here's
author Goa against Arthur Zoo very
complicated position wow well this is
kind of crazy can I try to Checkmate on
the back I was about to say yeah
shouldn't we maybe uh maybe we can this
night on C5 makes a very pleasing
impression by the way this move Rook F1
uh obviously and he captures we have a
big problem so if we take with the
Knight then Queen d8 check right forcing
that capturing on F6 and this is where
once again we've got the same issues
funnily enough when our Knights on G4
we have a rook check ourselves so the
current position
with captures on E5
is there something else that black can
do F5 I think the current position is
just uh game over game over in fact
that King on h8 is okay just a second
before I resign
can I go down swinging can I can I die
on my terms
you can't you certainly can that's the
next chapter in Christian's new book
I've seen this made before yes
exactly makes perfect sense right until
the point that you gave me mate in one
Queen f8 made in one very nice it's a
beautiful move yes sir yes one issue
that's about it you're right
and uh wow okay so this one looks like
white is winning Archer goes winning uh
we think uh Balaji is making a draw we
think Josiah is winning and in the
ladies the girls pardon me we have uh
just one game remaining Rochelle
what a blunder by Rochelle oh no because
that allows her opponent a past
absolutely
the queen side the one thing you don't
want to do is give your opponent
these a way to make a past pawns right
yeah keep the pawn on G7 that's right
that was a that was a blunder this is a
very strange decision by Rochelle um May
but her time I mean she still has 14
minutes you know what she may be
thinking about let's go G6 H5
yeah and then like if I capture capture
then F5 H6 and F4 and thinking like I'm
still holding on to that pawn my pawns
can be running but the problem is why
it's going to create two past pawns
right yeah yeah
and uh oops
and we have a draw in the Juniors yes we
saw those checks going back and forth
and you know what the problem is in that
position I think if you try to stop me
with something like Bishop to F5 so
handshake of Justin Wang and Balaji
dagupati yes as expected this one
going into the repetition while back
and she played H5 I mean she did you
were about to say that the problem is
Bishop F5 yeah whenever you try to stop
me from going to G4 I think at some
point I will be able to just sacrifice
my Bishop Bishop takes F4
isn't that
probably winning
and something like okay you keep the
king over on this side and then just
King G5 for King E5
and you so I I do have to be careful
obviously but
it feels like it should be five I think
King F6 yeah
should be winning but uh I think
Rochelle was probably hoping that these
two connected past pawns were going to
keep
White's King out that she would be able
to keep a fortress and hold it but I do
believe you're right that uh a bishop
sacrifice
whether it's based on
the position with B5 and A5 or but just
Bishop takes F4 three three pawns for
the bishop will likely win the game
okay but you do have to find this bishop
sacrifice because if you do not
sacrifice the bishop then it's no clear
way to how to win exactly okay we'll
keep an eye on that and uh the game
between Igor and Malik said has
come completely around in Full Circle
and gosh knows what else we have a rook
and Knight versus Rook
should be winning but okay the problem
is this black king if it's anywhere
close to the beep on it's there's
nothing to discuss it's game over the
fact that it's so far away gives white
Simple Plan right Rook C5 Rook C7 and
just capture the last spawn and you're
good yeah exactly draw King B6 Rook B8
capture the last pawn and you're good
how do we stop that uh Christian that's
a question for you
we don't we don't we don't we don't it's
a draw
oh no this one is a win
so what do you do
well we do have Knight E5 on the board
where she played yes and I'm
anticipating King B6
okay the Knight C4 I assume I'll give
you another check that's a good move
Knight C4 Channel okay I I have to keep
my king as active as possible I'll go
King A7 dreaming the dream of Rook C5
well can I go B5 now B5 check King A6
check again rookie six
you cannot touch the pawn I'm gonna put
my Rook on B6 so that this is just going
to be wow V6
wow and I'll just get your king closer
yeah and this doesn't work because the
pawn is faster but okay this is
difficult to find right Rook B6 it's not
the only way uh yeah there may be other
uh that's the problem
but what uh what a game and the joke
game Joe Benjamin versus Dimitri game
that was a game that we felt
had three results going forward
somewhere back to the white king from B1
got back to the king size yeah when we
left it we had Rook to H1 right and we
were thinking anything can happen here
and then what happened it feels like the
current position has gone in Joel's
favor like a lot of things happened that
was favorable for white first of all
our Center is nice solid and safe this
Knight on B6 makes a woeful impression
right we can play B3 and the Knight on
B6 is is out
um we've kept all of the uh goodness in
the position including our Pawn is on H5
still and we just went upon
this is gone tremendously in Joel's
favor I want to say enough we once we
play Knight C5 we're securing victory
looks well so if Black Goes Knight C4
and we go Knight C5 that's a Tempo
against the world yes and I go Rook E8
no my am I leaving my king victim to
some horrible undertaking after B3
you're not worried about your king at
all I I I bravely will take my move back
as soon as you demonstrate uh something
harsh all right so I'm going to give you
check on F5
Knight to D6 look at you I want to go to
B5 tactics tactics
oh no that's that's not fair oh no I'm
gonna play G5 like a professional okay
and with Elan with Grace just put it out
there capture and passan and Knight B5
hmm
wow
wow uh and Knight B5
so let's capture ambassan and Knight B5
you hit my Rook you hit my Pawn
and yeah and then E5 is gonna fall right
well it's still like it I mean I'm I'm
lots of Pawns up uh check okay
Knight F3 be careful a lot of stuff is
happening that one getting me from okay
let me try to do something like this
after your knight B5 move Knight takes
E5 yeah Knight V5 I'm gonna go Rook F7
Rook S7 tactics you're trying to tactic
me I'll tactic back yeah well there's a
lot of white Pawns in the position
that's the problem that uh the Dima is
facing it's uphill battle so Knight
takes a four yeah no this doesn't work
yeah this is a very good defense
you you like Knight A4
Nook F7 yeah
um good idea but not a great execution
sorry I'm just going to quickly refresh
my board because I was really surprised
by the decision to play Knight A4 like I
mean even if you win this Pawn on B2
and do can you win the pawn on B2 so you
can force Knight trade with Knight C5
but maybe that is what black wants to
just go to a rook end game exactly
it would be nice if your night was uh
was already on B2 I'd have a rook check
night here night here and night coming
to fa so yeah I'd almost like you to
take this Pawn so you want to play King
F3 just to well then you can't take the
pawn I'll take you tonight
I just don't need to play anything
exactly like yeah please take the go go
for it um
hmm how do I
um
let's see what's happening there right I
can if I can double the Rooks no uh
you'll take on H5 sorry no Christian
wants to go 95 14.
Rook takes okay he went for it and rugby
six right yep
so and how can I hide my king somehow
King where do I hide it is okay F1 so
that
you you want to take the pawn obviously
maybe that's the way yeah
and you want to
I'm not saying that you necessarily want
to do this but if you can if you if you
ever get into two versus two
like you take right and we get something
like this
and you go after the H Pawn I think this
is really really really bad I just think
that White's pawns are too far up the
board and I will be the one cleaning my
pawns while yours are still at the
Starting Gate you know
and Knight takes C5 on the board will
take C5 they're going into this Rook
ending Joel uh looks like he's doing
very well in the battle of the Arthurs
let's just go there very quickly because
we are expecting a result I'm not sure
if we are
um because he has been thinking after
this move Rook F1 41 for quite a long
time
and I don't think we have a move on the
board do we no at least for like 20
minutes I think he's been thinking about
he's really thinking maybe resignation I
don't know like what is he thinking
about I would guess he's thinking about
F6 F5 and trying to maintain that Knight
on G4 because there is these back rank
mate issues right like you know it would
really take we we need white to do as a
great service and capture this Pawn on
CAT5 so that we have this uh chance to
get back into the game with Rook B1 so
I'm assuming it has to be F5 because all
of these moves any capture on E5 is
being met by Queen DHS as Kate pointed
out and I was dead
I was just dead and so I can't play
Knight takes E5 I can't play F6 takes C5
so it's got to be a five or maybe he's
thinking about just sacrificing an
exchange like Rook takes C5 Queen takes
C5 and Knight takes E5
but the pawn on A6 is going to fall and
the whole position is probably gonna
fall yeah
B1 and get the rookie involved in in the
game and we have a move H5
after all of that we couldn't guess uh
his move no takes on E5 no F5 H5
wow
that looks bad
I mean not surprisingly but yeah that
looks really bad
you can take on on the east on US ah
Queen the the reason why I was really
saying it's bad Queen A7 F7 right but we
do have Knight takes F6
that's a surprise move
because Rook takes F6 as Rook takes
no what am I saying this must be winning
this must be completely winning guys
yeah yeah we should go there nothing the
seniors in the junior girls Rochelle the
only game that we still have left
Rochelle versus mangalam mangalam with
the white pieces after this move G6 H5
F5 was Rochelle's invitation to the
complete change of structure in the
position if I go H6 right yeah age six
you have to go F4 I go back you go G5
you have to stop me from playing H7
right otherwise I queen right right
and this was the position that she
needed to assess is it winning or is it
not and it seems like the answer is
pretty clear it's completely winning
because I'm going to go Bishop to B2
right you don't have a way to go E4 big
because that's going to allow me to go
uh H7 King to C1 followed by H7 so you
have to be careful about that
but next I'm going to go A4 B5 I'm going
to use my pawns on this side as Decoy
for your king then I'm just going to
Simply pick up your own f g Pawn because
they're stuck right right you don't have
again if you push F3 I go King E3 I stop
everything this is game over so
big big missed opportunity I understand
why she didn't do it because sure it is
a little bit difficult to allow these
pawns to start rolling down the board
the E and F Pawn for black she did not
do that she played G takes F5
G takes H5 but this is just after GTX F5
this is problematic F6 King E6 I'm
catching your pawns B5 but now I'm just
simply going to take you take back
I'm going to go Bishop to A2 I need to
stop your pawns right I cannot take I
don't have time for that because of B6 I
don't have the E4 Square for my Bishop
so I need to get my Bishop ready to stop
your pawns but I can do that simply by
Bishop to A2 you go here I go here I
stop your pawns I pick up this guy and
that's it then I bring back my king this
is an easy draw right now easy draw so
Rochelle has
she was dead in the water in this one
just on that once more a b c Bishop B B
yes now I understand B6 is not going to
bring home the bacon but A4 but
therefore I can go Bishop C4 right ah
exactly you you you keep me honest
and I don't even have to do it
immediately I can just take on F6 she's
captured and then you go A5 I go this is
the key moment Bishop A2 and she'll save
the game and that well you know
sometimes that's what it takes is it's
not always about winning it's about
saving the bad games I mean you have a
few games in a tournament that you
really need to save right right and then
you have a good chances to actually be
winning because those critical moments
could be those actually decisive ones
indeed so Bishop A2 and she's got 10
minutes no huge uh huge save for
Rochelle if she finds Bishop to A2
because she was on the back foot the
whole game this is the opening she was a
pawn down she never recovered right
mangalam really did a good job to
increase her Advantage but then just at
the final moment she didn't capitalize
how many times does the end game you
know that slip that you know you you
play a perfect game four or five hours
and just then one move we always say
that rather interest that's so brutal
you don't see it in tennis you don't see
it anywhere exactly which has one
painful truly painful truly
wow good job Rochelle I know that's how
we save a game we should play too well
she's a woman's Grandmaster for a reason
right I mean it's uh you know I remember
she was also on the U.S women's national
team when I was also there uh in
Kazakhstan world team championships and
she was just celebrating her 13th
birthday there we were like wow she's
already in the national team and she's
only 13 uh but look at her now she's
older she's at Stanford she's yeah woman
Grand Master no no she's not yet in
University oh it's Carissa oh okay I
know that because I'm trying to get her
to myself
you're a recruiting coach I'm recruiting
around here I remember at the US
championship last year Rachelle and
Jennifer came to me at the opening
ceremonies
you know you're bad you're bad as a
commentator we we could do a lot better
than you guys you know uh Jennifer and
Rochelle we should be the commentator I
said please
come on the show take my spot take my
spot I'd love it really what what
you're really talented players truly
Bishop A2 nice nice save but I do want
to go to the Juniors because Igor
navikov and melecation well that's not
the Juniors oh sorry the seniors
because it was super close when we go
back one move only medic played exactly
with Igor what we what computers
suggested check B5 check
check you cannot capture the pawn you
have to move back which is right and now
the last move computer was suggesting
Rook B6 and black is winning correct
right
but that did not happen Knight E5 so
should also still be winning 95 because
the problem is is the the all black king
needs to do is just come on over right
and we are having a check issue too King
B7 King G4 sorry Kate what what would
you like to say about the position no
I'm just wondering if this were Works
without looking kind of being stuck
there so if I go Rook F1 okay Rook F1
looks like a very decent move and
somehow this construction I I'm gonna go
back with uh Christian's idea of just
sticking the Knight on C4 and playing
Rook to B6 maybe he's worried that he's
not going to be able to pass the f file
yeah I'm just gonna you know okay hand
my Rook on the file yeah let me just do
something of this nature right now I'll
go Knight C4 and you'll manage this
right I'll I'll wait and then check can
you say here I'll wait and I will go
here
So eventually if you do trade
I'm gonna stick my knight yeah this is
only A3 Square yeah and then that's easy
right then my king will eventually make
its way to
your Pawn well that seems like lazy plan
except I don't know he has his own
approach he has his own approach
he played Knight
F3 so he's trying to get the king there
he wants to cross this way
makes sense makes sense because the
night will always be able to defend the
d e like if we shift right if we shift
our Rook so perhaps this is what he's
calculating just that uh we'll have the
night and we will slowly slow I mean it
takes time but but it works too it works
there's a lot of ways to win here the
more challenging would be to go Rook D1
I'm sorry what would be more challenged
Rook D1 Rook David yes one
it makes it but now I think I can go
King F4 Rook D5 and now Rook E5 right
yeah
and if you do take on E5 I take with the
King not with the Knight and then you
just plant the Knight on D4 and
eventually you will worm your way to the
C4 Square yes wow uh for he's done it
his he's done it
yeah what a recovery from this yeah kind
of tough middle game well I remember at
a sinkhole cup making a toast
um Wesley so had just won the tournament
in
uh Wesley had been last and then first
so I said from the lowliest to the
holiest
Wesley so and we have a result so yeah
we have a result uh in the Juniors
between Arthurs yeah Arthur Gua and
Arthur Zhu what is the result I believe
white one Arthur gold one yes yeah
that was the H5 game
after
all of that long thing takes takes
who really put up a good fight right
right
let's not forget he's the lowest rated
player in this event by a large margin
great game yesterday against Balaji
amazing that's the bottom right great
opening great middle game great
execution in the end
and today he didn't play a bad game it
was just that the other Arthur was the
other man today that's it
it looks like again a whitewash as white
is really scoring a lot well first of
all a lot of decisive games to begin
with 60 decisive games in two of the
section 100 in the other section but
white is wearing winning far more than
his shirt that you would expect and it
looks like Josiah is winning again it's
the queen versus the two Rooks uh
against me and two pawns yeah when we
left it it wasn't even clear
that white wouldn't win a third Pawn
here and he's got A5
check check
intriguing
so he's just ready to rumble up the
board Jack Jack
and check on D6 pardon me and B6 uh
I know it's winning uh Christian but is
it one of those
you know you have to win it precisely or
is it there are many it shouldn't be
like that right
um of winning I mean right it should be
easy you'd think somehow it feels like
it should be easy right but maybe it's
not that easy okay what if I just after
Rook to uh H1 what if I just try to push
my kick let's go King before and if you
give me a check I'll go King C5 well
give me another Chicago King thesis the
king beef King trying to be aggressive
one of the things I love is just
centralizing the queen and perhaps
that's when when I say centralizing I
mean most specifically one of these four
squares so if you could do it uh with a
gain of tempo like if you could go check
check you know and you know your queen
is on any of these four squares then I
like this because it's sort of like the
queen you know covers so many of those
squares for the Rooks that's probably
the technically correct way of doing
things okay but you you you're I'm just
trying to to go directly yeah yeah your
approach may just maybe I make some
mistakes let's see if black has any
chance of let's find some way out right
yeah exactly let's take a look in check
check check I go King D6 I go all the
way up King D6 and let's say I do my
best to hang oh and that's the question
right now do I hang on no I can't go
King B7 I'm forced to play Rook C8
it's still not easy I mean okay I
so long as I haven't you know blundered
a rock so now I probably have to go
something like Queen to E2 but I mean
Queenie two Rook B4 and that's actually
the way to mess it up yeah you could you
could you start the feeling that you've
you've lost the connection here that's
that's the way to mess it up right
so uh maybe uh we'll require a little uh
technique here what other remaining
games do we have we think Rochelle is
drawing
we do think that
Alexa is going to win in Joel Benjamin
versus Dimitri
yeah so we have he's already won the
pawn on D5 by the way so that's very
very bad news for Dimitri as he is
two pawns down
yeah B2 Pawn is defended that's
that's healthy two Palms down it's a
very healthy coupons right but okay as
white you still need to put up the
finishing touches so something like I
don't know C8 looks nice yeah
okay
now there's like this pause is what am I
supposed to do next and it happens
so imagine I play Rook before hoping
uh to try to put some pressure on the
Pawns
try to give check
what am I supposed to do
feel like I I mean I'm just doing my
best to try yeah to try to
create a little bit of chaos but I I do
think that the pawns are just eventually
win yeah but it's not that simple like
if I capture on G7 you capture on D4
okay yeah
[Music]
yeah we don't want to simplify it too
much it's
and if I play Rook to D2 and you take on
H5 and you've got to check
you're kicking yeah and the time you
know we see that uh Joel Benjamin is
having eight minutes
um
he did not yet play the move Rook C7
check but we were thinking that that was
the way to go all right something to go
rookie two I I feel like we should go
through this Josiah versus uh let's do
it
just because I'm starting to see some
ghosts
King before was played without the
centralization without the central which
I already don't like
because after this move came to C5 which
is on the board Rook to C7 yes
King D6 first of all is the only way to
win already
seven and now King D6 is the only move I
mean that makes sense right we are
attacking The Rook improving our King
op4 is defended sure after King to B8
there are suddenly only one move that
wins only one only one move in this
position oh I see that C4 C5 does not
win I saw that that's a blunder this is
already starting to become study like
wins almost wow Queen G8 is the only way
to win Queen GA Queen GA now the problem
is uh this desirable King B7
no you probably go Brook C8 right
and he does it this is not easy anymore
guys this is uh just might be the save
of the tournament
I don't know I mean there are a lot of
saves today no no because yesterday
against Dimitri that was Carissa saved
today right I mean Rochelle Rochelle
says yeah so right now after Rook C8
has drawn yeah speaking of her show she
did manage to make a draw and it's a
first row for uh Shrek a mangalam after
the first loss in the first round uh she
made a draw Rook C7 check we're
expecting King D6 then we're expecting
after King B8 you're about to tell us
Christian a queen G8 is the only winning
path correct why is it so narrow and
followed by Rook to C8 okay now the only
winning move is Queen G3
threatening a discovered check and now
when you're taking my Pawn
I go King D7
what exactly and King B7
Queen to G2 once again only move this is
some study likes I have no idea what's
happening on the board it's crazy if you
go on the eighth rank I have Queen G8 if
you go on the sixth rank I have Queen G6
if you go on the a file I have Queen A2
so now your Rook one of the Rooks is
lost wow and King B6 queen queen G6 good
luck finding all of this wow that's but
that's really pretty it is pretty but it
was unnecessary and Josiah is going to
be very angry when he starts seeing all
these crazy and by the way King B8 is on
board yeah King yeah there was no from
in some ways mishra's play is so easy
because everything loses on the spot
that move loses that move loses I only
have one move I have to play the move
King B8 because everything else is so
Dreadful I mean so far he's finding
everything but he has only less than
five minutes left to the end of the game
is starting to feel confident right I
mean you start hoping for something here
well this is already some kind of alien
business
[Laughter]
that doesn't look like Queen GA to me
that didn't look like a queen they're
like Queen G4 I think Queen D5 I think I
thought that was that was what it looked
like was Queen because the idea is
you're kind of fearful well you are
fearful of Rook D1 check
uh you you know and you so Queen D5 to
stop Queen pardon me stop Rook T1 check
makes but Queen T4 makes sense too right
you are guarding the pawn you are
guarding the one square
correct and you are thinking about
playing C5 maybe I don't know but the
pawn is still on B5 hanging
well the good thing for Josiah he has 17
minutes so a lot of time to think
and uh we as Josiah is thinking we have
guest in studio with Christian Arthur
congratulations you won the Battle of
the Arthurs this was a difficult game I
guess an opponent sure much more rated
but definitely in shape in this
tournament he showed it yesterday how
did you get ready for this one what was
your approach
um just the usual I mean like I just
wanted to get a game and that's what I
did
um
I think I played shaky chest to be
honest it was wild chess but it looked
quite interesting and this was perhaps
the critical moment right when he played
this move Rook to B5
after Queen to D2 it seems like you're
Gathering quite a significant Advantage
maybe Knight to D6 was the move did you
spot this one and how did you assess
this yeah I did I I didn't really think
he played it I just played H4 because I
thought he would play Rook B5 yeah um to
stop you from going H5 exactly it was
just the most natural move he was
already getting like down to three
minutes here yeah and so I was just
playing off kind of intuition were you
uh happy with your position at this
point uh I mean I thought that's it in
your favor I thought it was winning yeah
like close to winning at least
and then once you picked up but there
was there's a moment I got to it outside
that he had a chance wait at what point
um after F4 or 905 Queen C4 oh
okay Knight F5 Queen C4 yeah Rook D5 is
oh my gosh
oh this is waiting for you yeah did you
you spotted no no yeah we
I I didn't spot it that this is too hard
but he played like King h8 immediately
yeah but I got told outside Rook D5 is
just insane Rook D5 wins on the spot
yeah
wow what but by the way at this point
you guys both had well he had one minute
you had three minutes still a few moves
to go Rook to D5 was not played but
water blow yes and after King to h8 it
feels like
you kind of took over and never let it
go after that
an important victory for you
how is the preparation coming into this
event did you spend time looking at the
games of your opponents or what was I
don't really do much I've been playing
like five tournaments in a row so you've
been having a busy summer yeah yeah
exactly
um but yeah I mean the preparation year
was good
um he was like up to like move 18 or
something I was in prep but I mean
like I think I think prep doesn't really
matter that much these days especially
when there's so many like opportunities
for your opponent to go wrong so what do
you uh what attributes do you focus on
in your training to develop what skills
do you focus on
um I think
I think the biggest like
key for me was just to play like smart
chess and just like follow the
principles not getting careless in a way
um and like being able to just hold a
draw against these people because half
points are always you know important
especially in these tournaments so yeah
playing smart chess sticking to just the
principles thus like the basics you know
I don't think anything can go wrong
staying resilient playing Fighting Chess
that's definitely a good recipe
congratulations we'll see you in the
next round thanks congratulations Arthur
absolutely as uh the game of uh Josiah
and uh Mishra he didn't play that move
Queen G8 yeah
a hard move to find he played Queen E2
which looks okay you know you're
defending the pawn on C4 but it gives up
this was the exact line that we
discussed at the beginning right we said
that this is the way to mess it up and
and indeed he has he's he's messed it up
with this the the the rushing of the
king I think he had to centralize his
king queen first Queen on e4 Queen on D4
Queen on the D5 and by
advancing with his King too early he's
left to see four Pawn behind Okay that's
that's a difficult pill to swallow
because you played such a great game
right you had an incredible chance to
beat one of the favorite the event's
favorite I mean question okay so look at
him what if I go Christian like King D5
and dance around with the king I know
you're gonna give them I take on C4 all
right that's it that's the problem and
then I've got uh the king in front of
the pawn it just became pleased for me
yep yeah this is this is heartbreaking
right now wow heartbreaking stuff
by the way uh not for nothing but after
Rook check
okay you're a big city
[Laughter]
I just wanted to ask
do you want to take it
be nice be nice
yeah this one is over it seems like
America got the victory in this with the
extra night what a game two out of two
what a star to the singers championships
yeah but uh truly uh
to my for for me he was just lost out of
the opening and he was and castles long
at that moment Igor was plus five
according to the kind of quiet attention
my goodness yeah that's a sad loss what
a great start middle game and then and
let's just jump if we have first of all
I'm just looking this I I'm almost going
to predict that I will predict this we
won't have five draws in the girls
tournament in any other round not a
single round you heard it here first
commentators curse by the way uh but uh
Joe Benjamin versus Dimitri that's uh uh
remaining in the senior section as the
seniors today are duplicating the
Juniors of yesterday
very fighting oh wow all the sizes all
decisive games that's what I mean to say
after the move before let's catch up
with the players check nope sorry I this
is not that was the analysis of
apologies we left it at Rook before
right here Rook d8 was played King E7
and we're catching up with the players
and now we have the current
game live
so I'm assuming we have to play King to
D1 to to keep the pawn on B2
under a watchful eye but then there is
no I said
don't hold me hanging Rook H3 or Rook D3
but maybe none of that well Rook D3 I
was going to play and then Rook H3 I
just want the Rook kind of out of the
file
maybe there's no reason for that for
that and I think uh we're going to see a
shake of hands in the abimanu versus the
Jose as the players have gotten to that
King and pawning game that's a dead draw
yep
yeah
one Josiah probably feels like he missed
a chance here it's a big disappointment
yeah big big disappointment for shaza in
this one
talk about the one that got away
we will see a stalemate
because he did you know he didn't play a
perfect game by any means had a good
position
allowed I'll be money back in the game
there not be money didn't find that B6
move crazy move to save the game yeah
but then you got an easy technical win
and then you have to stop and convert
that can you check handshake and quickly
let's go look at it in the other room
he's really disappointed Josiah we could
see it here he just like
yeah he knows he he knows he had it in
the back yeah by the way that move Rook
D3 check that was played by Dimitri I
feel that that was
a bad move because I suggested no no no
because it just gives Joel the
opportunity of releasing his Rook so for
example The Rook came to DJ like the
Rooks in the way I mean we would love to
just play D4 or D5 let's go let's go and
this move Rook to G6 also it just feels
like you're just giving me the Tempe
that I need to well I mean look at this
uh yeah this is it's really really fast
suddenly maybe you can go Rook C6 now
Rook C6 ah so that yeah I was about to
say so
but now that you've managed to put your
Rook on on that square
right
so here's what's wrong with Rook G2
no sorry
it was supposed to be Rook to G2 and
meeting Rook uh to C4 with the G4 okay
uh Joel so with his extra two pawns we
think that Joel is on his way to Victory
and that will be the fifth
victory in the seniors five for five
seems we have one section that gets all
decisive games
but we see Joel having less than three
minutes right so there's not that much
time to think but here it is okay okay
well those moves Rook to D3 check and
Rook the G3 have invited uh White to
position his Rooks but how easy I mean
I'm
are we sure that that endgame is that
easy after Rook takes G6 and Rook C6 or
maybe even King E6
well he's done it Rook takes G6 H takes
G6 which one would you prefer okay let's
go King E6 okay
and they need a new score sheet so they
just finished 60 moves right well the
idea was to play D5 check but it's
starting to become some sort of a race
right right King takes E5 D6 Rook d8 uh
he's going for he's going for the
blockade right so
for some reason I was being dismissive
okay this is starting to become a race
guys I mean I'm not sure if he's winning
this one
objectively maybe still winning but from
a practical perspective this is not an
easy task exactly very similar to what
Josiah did uh just played a couple of
moves that felt natural right and then
suddenly you're no longer winning right
or suddenly Things become double-edged
well if I play Slowly King E2 and King
E3 well the king is just going to assert
a beautiful blockade The Rook will come
back and you'll eventually use your H
Pawn as a decoy that's right you
probably trade off to a draw that's
right yeah
well let's take a look at the standings
now that the history books of the round
two are in the history round two down
for the girls juniors and this is the
standing after round two we have Alice
Lee rochellebu and Zoe tank leading the
tournament with one and a half points
then there is Karissa Peru Yang Yen
kelsilio and Rose Atwell with one point
and irismo Gracie prasanna and Shreya
mangalam half a point and for the
juniors
so just standing after round two we have
Andrew Hong with perfect score two out
of two then Brandon Jacobson abimanio
Mishra and Kirk gazarian with one and
half points Arthur Gua and Arthur Zhu
both Arthurs having one point and Balaji
dagupati Justin Wang and Josiah steerman
with half a point and Jason Liang so far
with zero
wow the sixth the tie for six has
changed with one game remaining for the
seniors uh all decisive so far yes
loogie won against wolf shabalov lost to
kaidanov acopian won against Ruth
navikov lost to kachian and yes one game
remaining two versus uh Dimitri Joel
enjoying a two Pawn Advantage but it's
one of those moments where we feel
there's some awkwardness that's going on
there definitely is there is a skink on
D5 blockading coupons active Rook yeah
and the problem is the Pawn on G6 is
vulnerable and upon Him B2 is not
partaking if you will so King E3 we
would expect the Rook to drop back to C6
and say okay how are you defending the
pawn and then this Rook could
for a two Pawn Advantage it sure doesn't
feel like an ice cream on Advantage
right yeah
so maybe we can expect Rook C6 Rook G2
back right and then you are using the
decoy with H5
yes the question is should I be like
what's the ideal Square maybe B6 is the
ideal Square because from B6 I hit G6 I
hit G2 or just as you said should I
immediately set about going for the the
plan of trading my H bond for the G6
Bond I kind of like that I can play
check
yeah sorry uh it's kind of like Rook B6
you do yeah Rook G2 Rook B6 somehow I
like that move too I am going to play
King F4 King F5
trying to sneak
sneak by with King F4 and King F5 uh
okay I'll take on D4 all right
well check
yeah okay C4 yeah it kind of kicks you
away from
is on the board
by the way Rook C6 yeah Rook C6 so I was
expecting Rook G2 I have another idea by
the way if you move back for a bit sure
here okay stop here uh no Rook Rook B6
King F4 sorry G2 Rook G2 Rook B6 got it
King F4 got it can we be Sleek here with
just Rook B3 here so I'm inviting you to
go King F5 so I can check you on F3
that's nice I mean boy that is nasty um
I I need to
my Rook right I need to this King on D5
is so strong I'm thinking that if you go
King E6 I'll even sacrifice a pawn
to get my my guy going no I won't pardon
me I apologize I'll at last
this is the dream right I apologize so
so rugby three doesn't work so it's it's
pretty complicated so it's probably
white winning here
maybe maybe the two pawns is enough Rook
V6 might be a bit too easy okay I'm
making life easy for you why don't I go
Rook C1 well try to uh what about the
decoy if you want that Decoy move okay
well but the problem with H5 don't I
have
Rook G5
sorry I do not have a G5
Rook to G2 H5 Rook to G5 H4 E6
E6 check don't touch that I wanted to
you know I did King has to go back now
D5
D5 oh nasty nasty I just feel like once
I push my pawns that close to promotion
yeah it does feel like you've making
some Pro I wow it's still maybe Rook h15
now by the way
but what if we show viewers why not to
capture the pawn on E6 before we go
never mind we can go back to the current
position okay but something else
happened yeah yeah a lot of moves a lot
of moves happen King E3 Rook C6 Rook D3
inviting Rook takes G6 which was
accepted and Rook C3 and Joel said
I want to play Rook check that's fine
I'll give you a check first which I will
be the first to check you
in King F4 and has he done it right so
we're not we're not interested in this
this is
probably a losing King upon it in game
for black
so we have to go Rook here
and you can see Joe Joel doesn't like
this I mean he knows something went
wrong yeah I mean he's not happy about
the position right now
well just because he had them much
easier win even if this is still winning
and that is very very questionable this
is the
current position
uh is Dimitri trying to determine
whether or not he can play this no wait
no no no way right he can't he has to
play Rook Rook G to his his question
right now just feels more natural
because I'm also attacking a pawn at the
same time but what would have attracted
Joel to this position why would he give
up his G6 Pawn
what happened here Kate this
I'm sad that the opponent G6 is gone and
I'm worried about time
two minutes two minutes less than three
minutes okay but still still possible I
guess no I think it's
it's one of those
um
trends that you start experiencing
during the game
you know you're winning and then slowly
slowly that win becomes more and more
difficult to achieve and you make more
and more repetitive mistakes just
because
you want that pressure to be gone you
want to finish the game you want to win
the game right right and you know you
want it to be over you want it to be
over exactly yeah oh I have an idea here
what about Rook G3
well that was my question why didn't I
put my Rook on G2 because if I had
played Rook to G2 and you have played
Rook to G3 and I would have played G5
check and you would play at least in
this position I could take the pawn in
the game position he put his Rook on G1
and your question is well what about
Rook G3 but now I go G5
maybe King G4 or
also a little hesitation on that Let me
refresh my board but I like that move to
you know attack the pawns and maybe
threaten Rook D7 check so what's the
story here if I take the ball I give you
a check on D7 and I run with my Pawn
good for you
how far do you get that's the question
uh so if I go Rook here you're gonna go
King F5 right correct
okay just a second I I'm I'm I'm
wondering should I give you a check
first and I think we are seeing yeah
we're seeing it on the board King takes
D4 has been played sorry
this is the current position we're
expecting well maybe I can go King C5
then King C5 yeah which is probably a
better move E6
and King C6
mean wow that e-pawn won't win the game
by itself
you have to go Rook to d8 yes yes
now it's important that I get my uh Pawn
be my Rook pardon me behind the pawn
okay
so the H Pawn no don't give that pawn
don't give the pawn okay I'll give a
check
Rook D7
yeah he's saying don't give the pawn
just so H5 we just use the decoy let's
go
yeah and that looks even yeah looks like
uh
should have kept that G6 Pawn with the
Mover of G2 earlier
but also he's been playing the last few
moves slipping as if they're
forced of some degree I mean he hasn't
spent any time he had three minutes a
while back also he still has three
minutes he's been making very important
decisions too quickly yeah but Joel
Benjamin is just shaking his head not
being very happy about his position
check all right all right kinky five oh
wait is this the easy way
just like check your way
because you cannot go to G6 so King E5
Rook check King G King F5 Rook check
again Christian is right I can't go to
G6 because I have root F6
okay that's a nice wave if it works yes
I think and I think it does
that's a great save by Dimitri truly
well you know yesterday he was
victimized by a great save by Igor today
uh he turns the tables yeah it's all
about kaisa right the chess gods
one day you're the student you're the
teacher
yeah
Joe knows it this will eternally last as
one of my greatest most favorite quotes
was from vishianan he was asked by an
Indian journalist
what is it like to be the world chess
champion and this she said to the
journalist well every day I feel like an
athlete
some days I feel like an artist some
days like I feel like a scientist and
other days I feel like an idiot
one of my favorite quotes ever because
we all feel like idiots it's just as
brutal you just always make mistakes at
least you know in one game or another
but every day I feel like an athlete
some days an artist some days
a scientist and some days maybe
and the players are are heading
completely to a draw so we won't see
five decisive games we will see
fortecising not five decisive games yeah
okay why would you do this I'm not sure
but hello before and stuff like that
it's an extra check that I really don't
want to see deal with right and eat the
pawn and let's go
well King 75 let's go
capture that last baby yes
the crazy part is if black if White's
King were on C2 it would be the Mishra
ending yes
the very same stalemate
and we're not going to get this
stalemate we're going to get naked Kings
and the players are about to shake hands
yeah Joel Benjamin like no no what did
what have I done right
just let one get away
great battle between these two players I
have to say exactly well this uh again
another eventful round full of decisive
games but you're going to have to sum up
the round for us uh Christian so many
comebacks from so many players yeah no I
mean uh first of all I I believe in the
Juniors we got four decisive results and
only one draw and that could have been a
decisive result that should have been a
decisive result as well so definitely a
lot of Fighting Chess as Arthur put it
it's all about not necessarily about the
openings but definitely about the
resilience and the fighting Spirit of
the players and we can see that and
that's being displayed in all three
sections in the ladies in the girls
section in the seniors in the Juniors as
well just incredible just so far sure a
couple of mistakes here and there but
this is exactly what we like to see as
commentators and as fans as well a lot
of exciting chess up to this point yeah
and here we have our
[Music]
next we have the Juniors here
that was a big say I was really feeling
good about my pick up until the last few
moves rough really rough but I see that
begin is keeping the team spirit also
and here we have seniors right I went
with the defending champion who
unfortunately lost to Gregory today
Gregory is doing well yeah
uh what's this uh the Mizzou picks
a lot a great minds think alike yes well
we will see about that indeed indeed
indeed and uh let's just take a look at
the standings for the seniors as we have
two co-leaders wow Gregory kaidenov and
Alex at cachan both won both games
leading with two out of two then we have
Maxine bluegill the only person with one
and a half points and then we have a tie
for the Fourth Place vladimira kopian
Alex shabalov Joel Benjamin and Missy
gravich with one point Igor novikov with
half a point and so far Patrick Wolfe
and Douglas route with zero points we
are congratulations to Andrew who is our
sole leader in the Juniors as we wrap up
our coverage of these national
championships we hope you're enjoying
yourselves tell your friends where
you're hanging out we'll see you all
tomorrow
great great games and remember you can
join the conversation you can write
comments on YouTube Twitter twitch
Instagram Facebook we are happy to
answer any of your questions
good night everyone bye
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited